[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
well the Bird app seems to be held
together by duct tape and failing twine
that's what we would
use to hold [ __ ] together where I'm from
duct tape bailing twine you can't duck
it [ __ ] it
brings a whole new meaning to the word
Bird app our words sorry
two words Bird app
um you know I know a lot of you don't
like the Twitter talk but here's the
thing
is that this is uh an example a really
good example as a matter of fact
of what happens when you have
authoritarian rule like this is it
this shows you exactly what happens when
you turn over something that is
a people thing like democracy but at the
Twitter app is about the people right
I mean yeah it provides content and you
have a way to look at the news or laugh
at funny videos whatever the hell you're
there to do
our [ __ ] post whatever
here's the thing
it's people on the app and I mean
there's Bots but it's mainly
people gathering in a common area
and this is exactly what happens when
you have authoritarian rule what we're
seeing right before our eyes at Twitter
you have one person deciding all things
you have a band of miscreants who are
not the majority
who are normally just the absolute
deluded minority and Elon simps are
completely [ __ ] delusional
that this is this is the image of free
speech
and the reason why it's so comparable
to the magaga movement
is because the diluted masses
that are not only wagging the tail that
is wagging the dog
but encouraging the authoritarian's
delusion
absolutely encouraging it as if now
Twitter's not going anywhere folks I
know people are saying Twitter's dead
it's done it's going to crash into the
ground that is true to an extent it is
going to not be what you have known it
it's not going to be what you have known
it is a hundred percent going to change
when he says Twitter 2.0 he means 4chan
2.0 already this morning in my Twitter
feed in the lobby or the the Home tab as
it were
there's all already is starting to look
like 4chan
and I'm not sure if it's just my feed or
what the hell but it's feeding me a
bunch of garbage and it's suggestions
it's not people that I follow or things
that people that I follow or people that
follow me have suggested or liked or
commented on it's just a pure suggestion
and it's 410 4chan type [ __ ]
the deep deep dark right wing web that
is what Twitter is about to become
at least for the time being as
space Karen's reign
over Twitter continues
it's authoritarian rule
is is what it is
it was a publicly traded company
they had to actually answer to a board
and to the to the shareholders now some
say oh well that's that's kind of
capitalism and
right I get it
but again it's a form of some sort of
backstop to authoritarianism
may not be your
preferred
form of backstop
to authoritarianism but it is one
regardless of how you exactly feel about
a publicly traded company or capitalism
or the stock market or shareholders in
this country or even
investors
I really gave Elon way too much credit
I I mean I knew the guy was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] just a complete [ __ ] [ __ ] box I
mean Jesus Christ the guy is an
apartheid baby
and he spoon fed
from from a golden or diamond spoon I
guess
and he appears to have nothing but
success which is all a [ __ ] fraud
just like the rest of the macagas in
this country and in this world really to
be quite honest
he's bound to lose a certain portion of
his fortune for the time being this
guy's got so much [ __ ] money though
he isn't going to lose it for long more
of a I guess a reason to tax him into
Oblivion
but here's the thing Twitter Will
Survive
it's gonna be a [ __ ] trash Heap
I mean you think you'd think Twitter was
bad when they were moderating that
[ __ ] just imagine when there is
not one [ __ ] employee in the
headquarters right now
they got that [ __ ] shut down
doors are locked lights are off
this [ __ ] is running on its own
autopilot
now you say what does that have to do
with democracy it has a [ __ ] ton to do
this is a perfect example let me tell
you something there are going to be
people who study this case
of Elon Musk absolutely [ __ ] Dr nose
diving
this company that's probably worth 10 or
12 billion
and he paid 44 really more than that but
44 billion
and he he [ __ ] drove it into the
ground in less than a month
it is going to be studied for a hundred
years at least
as long as we all band together
I'm not gonna leave Twitter
I I know some people now I I have other
social media Jesus Christ you gotta have
[ __ ] thousand social a thousand
social media places
when you when you do this talking to a
microphone
and you want to provide a place for
anyone to watch it and hear it
to gather up
to engage because that's what this show
is about is engagement in your democracy
yeah I talk a lot a lot
but it is about engagement in your
democracy
that's the whole point
but isn't that the point of Twitter
isn't that the point of quote free
speech I mean this morning basically
Elon Musk is saying anyone who doesn't
like the app leave
what does that sound like ah you don't
like this country get the [ __ ] out go
back to your own country or whatever the
hell they say right which technically
elon's not from here
but this is a prime example
Prime
right out in the open
of what authoritarian
really
magaga brings you
this is what it does if you put these
[ __ ] in charge
and you take the rails off
these [ __ ] knuckleheads
he's a nincompoop
and really I I guess the other day you
said something about he plans on backing
DeSantis and not Trump which is not
surprising
um I would imagine that that Elon simp
universe is gonna want DeSantis over
Trump anyways
I mean they just can't handle a loser
so I don't know how many I don't know
how many companies Elon has to tank
before they turn on him but he's got
three of them right now
well more than that but three big ones
and uh
he's about to lose his complete [ __ ]
ass on one of them
and I don't know how long it's gonna
take for his electric vehicle company to
tank
it's publicly traded there's a board but
we don't know
how many votes he has on the board
and then there's SpaceX which relies on
us the government yeah we the people are
the government relies on us and our
subsidies
to develop the technology to send his
[ __ ] dildo Rockets into space
so I don't know how long it's gonna last
for his supporters to turn on him if he
you know he
loses two three four companies
drives them into the dirt now they're
excited about this by the way
oh [ __ ] these right wing crypto Bros
they are [ __ ] excited about this [ __ ]
they get to say anything they [ __ ]
want post anything they [ __ ] want
there ain't nobody there ain't nobody
moderating right now not a goddamn soul
they're excited about this holy [ __ ]
they can post anything they want they
think that's free speech by the way
like they literally believe we can say
anything and post anything we want and
that's free speech now it is
when you have an authoritarian at the
helm and he's allowing you to say that
but the thing is is Elon seems to be
moderating the voice against him
which
again is a tenement of [ __ ]
authoritarianism
where he's silencing and canceling and
turning off accounts that say anything
bad about him
but he's letting everything else go
that's you know in his support his his
shart Army you know I'd say Trump has a
sharp Army Elon has a sharp Army
but this is what happens when we have
authoritarian rule
over something that is built around
people
it's plain as day you can see it
this is why it is so important that we
engage in our democracy because they
can't buy our country
if we don't let them
or if we let them they may
but we must we must put people in power
who will not allow these [ __ ] chuckle
heads
to implement their policies like Elon
has done at Twitter and destroyed it
absolutely destroyed it now again it's
not dead I mean it's on [ __ ] life
this life support this morning I I was
wondering I I mean I'm still wondering
if this [ __ ] thing's gonna make it
through the weekend
the reason why is because I mean one
major thing goes wrong they're [ __ ] I
mean it it'll all [ __ ] unravel in in
moments
there's no security
on the app right now
there's no one protecting the app I mean
it's wide [ __ ] open
to be torn to the ground
and again if it happens it'll happen
probably within moments I get just won't
[ __ ] work
and it's going to be limping around
until someone get bats gets gets back to
the headquarters to fix it if he can
find somebody
that's the other thing that
authoritarians fail
at and it's obvious that this is uh been
a prime example of that too
is the people who built the app
the people who worked hard the
bureaucracy in other words of Twitter
you know they oh a big government big
guy you heard this [ __ ] big government
big government this big government that
be right accuracy you know they all get
[ __ ] all bent out of shape especially
Libertarians
get all bent out of shape
over big government
well this is a prime example what
happens when you don't have some sort of
bureaucracy to implement policy this is
what happens
you're gonna see it this [ __ ] thing
is gonna be just a [ __ ] nightmare
now Jack Dorsey was tweeting this
morning that it's not over
and it will be okay so I don't know if
Jack Dorsey is waiting in the wings
just to [ __ ] snatch this away from
him
I'm not really sure what's going on
there
um but it seems like Jack Dorsey is
signaling to users that hey stick around
We're not gonna let this [ __ ] thing
sink to the bottom of the ocean but boy
it's got holes in the boat doesn't it
doesn't it feel
like the Titanic right now like in the
movie when they're they're playing the
music and everybody's freaking out some
the the rich Folk
are trying to find the boat that they're
going on
whew
but I want to say that I am super happy
with
the state of our democracy
yesterday we watched Nancy Pelosi step
aside from leadership now the media is
blowing this out of the water they act
like she's [ __ ] dying or something
which again this this is all the media
sucks at this [ __ ]
she's still a congressperson she's still
going to be in Congress if you think
that Nancy Pelosi isn't going to be able
to talk if she wants to talk into a
microphone she'll be able to get a
microphone you're [ __ ] nuts
she's gonna be known as former speaker
of the house from here until she doesn't
want that seat anymore why are they
memorializing her like she's dead I
don't understand it it's [ __ ] really
stupid it's really [ __ ] dumb
to have a big conversation I mean yeah
you can like be like oh here's what she
did she was the first woman she did this
did this and this and this I said that
yesterday but she's not [ __ ] dead
she's not going anywhere she's gonna be
a member of Congress as long as she
wants to be a member of Congress so why
are they [ __ ] talking about this [ __ ]
when what they should be talking about
is the Republicans ran on gas prices and
the very first thing that they're gonna
do is talk about Hunter Biden's laptop
and the January 6th insurrectionists are
being treated unfairly they're political
prisoners
literally they're going to protect the
Traders
investigate something that doesn't exist
that's not that has already been
investigated
it's already been investigated
but they're gonna they're gonna make
[ __ ] up
and try to [ __ ] generate a narrative
that you should be scared of laptops
and this is why we can't let these
chuckleheads get in control of anything
now yeah they took the house by a few
votes and it's not going well for them
by the way
it only shows how weak the Republican
party is
and it only shows how strong liberalism
is if you if you want to know the honest
truth
I believe democracy is very strong in
this country this this midterm convinced
me that this democracy's fabric is still
intact and it still has strength
that as hard as they worked as hard as
they tried as much narrative as they
tried to really dig in and to scare
people to absolutely terrify them didn't
work it didn't [ __ ] work
matter of fact we got it looks like
we're gonna get 51 in the Senate because
we should lean into that race in Georgia
and make sure Warnock pulls it over the
line
because we have 51 in the Senate by God
we got full subpoena Power full
committee power we we as Pro to the
pro-democracy Coalition have the ability
to jam judges down their [ __ ] throats
and we should
but it only lays out clearly that the
majority of votes only have 51 senators
it only shows that this minority rule
thing is going to continue now I
understand these reforms don't happen
overnight
and I'm not going to sit here and and
bludgeon you with line item after line
item in a bill and how many Supreme
Court judges we should have and what the
[ __ ] minimum wage should be I'm not
going to do that [ __ ] because that's
dumb stupid [ __ ]
to be sitting here in a time like this
when [ __ ] is burning down and we're
trying to hose It Off
and now they got now
they got one fire department and they're
gonna be out there pouring gasoline on
Fires while we're trying to [ __ ] put
it out
so it's super important to stay engaged
so don't leave Twitter if you're on
Twitter find another place to copy and
paste your post
I know it feels like uh that's things
done it's dead and it may be for a while
it may be on life support for a long
time
and how it may never be revived to what
it was or once was just weeks ago
but it is super important that you stay
engaged in your democracy right now
especially at this race with Georgia
and I mean honestly if you're if you're
going to do anything for Warnock in
Georgia five bucks 10 bucks 20 bucks
whatever you can muster up to send him
and you send it directly to his campaign
directly to him
that's what you can do
now if you're good at texting making
phone calls do that if you're in Georgia
and you can knock on doors do that
because in Georgia apparently the only
people that can vote in this runoff are
people who voted in the midterm
Republican Democrat or libertarian
because there was three candidates on
the ballot I think there was like a
percent in a half that went to the
libertarian
so there's some of those votes still in
play
um of course
there's there wasn't much enthusiasm
behind Walker
uh that's kind of obvious we don't
really need to discuss too much of that
I can't even [ __ ] watch video of that
guy right now it's crazy
it's insane
I mean here's the thing he didn't expect
to have to run a campaign after a
campaign he didn't expect that he he
wasn't told that probably he wasn't told
that's what could happen and even if he
was told that hey if we go
to a runoff you're gonna have to keep
campaigning
because he just he I don't know he was
talking about a [ __ ] vampire movie or
some [ __ ] the other day holy [ __ ] I have
no clue what the hell he was trying to
say like it is
whoosh
I I can't even [ __ ] imagine going
into a voting booth and voting for that
for a United States Senate seat
I mean maybe maybe is like a mayor of a
small town or something or like a road
district manager or some [ __ ] but [ __ ] a
United States Senator
a guy who's telling a story about a
movie that he watched and you can't even
follow what the [ __ ] he's talking about
about the movie I mean that's the thing
here he can't even stand in front of a
microphone and explain a movie he
watched the night before
without you being confused as a
[ __ ]
and we expect that he's gonna be a
policy maker
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
nonsense
so you must lean in
because we can't do to our democracy
what Elon Musk has done to Twitter we
can't let it happen and we get to decide
that we are the shareholders of this
democracy folks the shareholders at
Twitter decided that it was worth the
money to sell it to that dumb [ __ ] and
get rid of it
we decide who we sell
our democracy too and we must we must be
diligent shareholders here in protecting
our country protecting our nation
protecting the Constitution protecting
our institutions of democracy it is
super important and yes are they banged
up
do they got a black eye from four years
of trump
and and are they gonna have a tough
fight now that we have these chuckle
heads you know running the House of
Representatives who knows God knows who
this [ __ ] speaker's gonna be it's not
gonna be Kevin McCarthy it doesn't look
like doesn't look like he's gonna have a
chance to win this here I don't know how
he pulls out 218.
but we'll see what happens with that
and really honestly let him [ __ ]
fight it out let them fight that's why
we should encourage Trump to run
DeSantis to run Ted Cruz to run [ __ ] yes
get in the race and start blooding each
other up and let's encourage it and
let's mock them like this Hunter Biden
[ __ ] do not engage in any kind of real
conversation about this Hunter Biden
stuff
it's not even worth it just mock them
just [ __ ] mock them laugh at them
because it is [ __ ] hilarious that
this is their [ __ ] platform they
really are going to [ __ ] do this to
themselves just like elon's doing what
he's doing to himself when he fired the
entirety of his staff at Twitter
they're going to destroy their party and
their chance of holding power anywhere
apparently this morning it is clear that
the uh I believe the Pennsylvania
uh house chamber has been taken back by
the Democrats
folks this election
was another [ __ ] rebuke on trumpism
and elonism
people in this country don't want that
[ __ ] nonsense they don't
and yeah they gerrymandered their way
back into the house
buy a few [ __ ] votes
but they're gonna demonstrate why we
should not put them in power of anything
just like elon's doing at Twitter
this is why these [ __ ] knucklehead
nincompoops should not have control of
anything they are [ __ ] [ __ ] they
do not respect the rule of law they have
no respect for people
it's all self-centered [ __ ]
only for their own [ __ ] Fame in their
own [ __ ] power that's it full stop
they have no forethought of what their
actions are going to do
to the people in this country or the
people on the app you know depending on
which one you're talking about the good
news about our country
is we are the [ __ ] shareholders
we the people are the shareholders of
our nation and our democracy it's ours
we don't have to rely on a group of
people who have a shitload of money
built into our democracy we do not have
to do that
we decide if we sell our democracy down
the river or not
we decide
not them everyone we got bonehead of the
week it is Friday Friday you know what
that means in the second hour of the
Tony Michaels podcast me and my co-host
Gabe Sanchez go through your vote
because you vote you decided who is the
bonehead of the week and we break it
down for you here on the Tony Michaels
podcast every single Friday so don't
forget to vote every single week you can
go to the if you're on YouTube right now
hit subscribe
we got over 12 000 subscribers yesterday
thank you very much you're the best
audience in the world but if you want to
vote just subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube you can go to the
community tab
click the community tab the the poll is
there you can also go to that [ __ ]
hellscape of Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod as long as that some [ __ ] is held
together by duct tape and bailing twine
we will have the poll there now I want
to tell you something about the bonehead
of the week next week we are going to
take a a vacation I have not taken a day
off
um this entire year I believe on a
weekday so this Thursday for
Thanksgiving I'm we're going to not have
shows on Thursday and Friday so we will
not have a bonehead of the week next
week but we will be here Monday Tuesday
Wednesday and we we will be celebrating
next week with you guys
um we will be we will be
giving you the results of what some of
these races are coming in as uh looks
like Lauren bober's race is going to go
to a recount
so we hope there's some good outcome for
that and that recount
um
but stay with us next week Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday we
will be off for Thanksgiving so have a
great break and we will continue to talk
about that next week so this is the bone
end of the week this Friday next Friday
we don't have a show so we won't be
doing the bone of the weeks but we will
bring it back the week after that you
know we will do bonehead of the week is
our favorite favorite segment here and
if you want to download bonehead of the
week you can always go download it on
Apple Spotify Google we put it up in and
of itself every single weekday every
single weekend you can also go watch a
short version of the bonehead of the
week on the Midas touch Network their
YouTube channel we used to do the whole
thing but we shortened it down we made
it shorter over there that way we just
get to the point of the winner of the
bonehead of the week so go check out the
Midas touch Network and check out the
shortened version of the bonehead of the
week you can also follow us on Facebook
I know you're on the Midas touch
Facebook page out there go follow us at
the Tony Michaels on Facebook and if you
like twitch
follow us on Twitch as well some people
like twitch over YouTube
and you're the best audience in the
world
I know I keep saying that but you really
are you really are the greatest audience
in the world because people come and
watch and they're here in the chat and
they're engaging about democracy every
single day right here live so make sure
to subscribe to the YouTube but if you
want to show support share this tweet it
remastered on it actually I think on on
Mastodon it's called a toot I don't know
I'm on Mastodon now you can go to the
tonymichaels.com and you can find the
Mastodon link there if you're going to
go over to Maston uh there's several
almost 200 people followed me already
just in the last few days so go go over
to Mastodon again you go to the Tony
michaels.com the Tony michaels.com to
follow me over there but go to Tony
Michaels dot live Tony Michaels dot live
if you want to give a tip the tip jar is
over there one time tip monthly tip look
here's the thing we could do super chat
here on YouTube but they take like 30 of
your money
which is ridiculous that's right they
charge you to give me a tip [ __ ] that
[ __ ] on the tip jar nothing like that so
go to Tony Michaels dot live Tony
Michaels dot live if you want to give a
one-time tip or set it up monthly we
appreciate that and if you can't if you
can't do the tip Perfect come watch live
re-watch share it with your family share
it with your friends even if they're
magogas macagas oh my God no it's
magagas
there used to be magas now they're
magagas
I don't know
if you want to show support and actually
receive something go to
store.dtonymichaels.com that's store not
the Tony michaels.com it's getting cold
outside the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people it's not Liberty
you know that's our
our Banner here at the Tony Michaels
podcast wear it loudly and proudly on a
on a zip up Hoodie
a hoodie a pullover hoodie or a T-shirt
and get it on a coffee mug as well if
you want it to make your coffee taste so
good so good so go to
store.the20michaels.com that's
store.the20michaels.com check out all
our merch there everyone stick around
we will be right back
right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing dance Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show some people are
wondering what server I chose on
Mastodon I didn't really understand a
lot of it I just joined the uh
mastodon.social I believe it's the one I
joined but if you go to the Tony
michaels.com the Tony michaels.com at
the top of the website there you will
find the link to Mastodon
um and I believe if you click it and you
don't have Mastodon already you can just
download it or if you're on a computer
you can just create an account otherwise
you can go download the app the app is
free
um and actually it's it's a it's not a
bad app
um like it it it's functions and it
looks a lot like the Twitter app like
you know there's a lot of familiar
things there's some things you cannot do
you can't like quote tweet
um or you can't embed tweet but you can
post and that's what a lot of people are
saying this morning we have a Discord
too and there's some people on Discord
um that are on our Discord you can find
that on D Tony michaels.com as well and
they they uh they go over there and they
talk in the Discord but Discord is more
like a conversation back and forth It's
like a you know
um it's a it's a conversation whereas
Mastodon you can post and leave like
Twitter
you don't I mean you can have a
conversation with folks over on Mastodon
but it's more of a of an archive a
posting site so
a little different
um form of social media so I don't know
a lot of people are saying they're going
to Reddit some people are saying that
they're going to Discord some people say
Instagram
um I'm I'm not that great at Instagram I
like them to post the memes over there
um you guys probably had caught that and
sometimes we post clips of the show uh
over there as well on Instagram so you
can follow us there and I love to post
the memes on Instagram on Facebook too
so you can follow us at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook and you can watch
the broadcast there as well as on the
Midas touch Facebook page we broadcast
this show on both those so
um as far as the Mastodon server and I
believe it is uh at Mastodon and I think
it's abbreviated
mstdn I believe that social is a server
Amazon but I don't think it matters what
server you're on necessarily you can
still follow
people on other servers I've noticed
that but I I will tell you about
Mastodon
is it's more you have to go find it of
what you want which is kind of good
right like they're just not serving you
up garbage like the algorithm isn't just
giving you a bunch of you know [ __ ]
that they think they it wants you to see
you actually have to go find what you
want to see on Mastodon so you got to
work a little bit which is a good thing
that's not a bad thing I think that's
the trouble that we've had with like
these q and honors out there on Facebook
is it just just absolutely spoon feeds
new just [ __ ] trash and and the more
trash they get spoon fed the more the
more trash it feeds them it's like a
goddamn dumpster fire
online so uh Mastodon seems to be all
right you know I I don't know we'll
we'll see where this thing goes but I'm
not gonna leave Twitter I'm still gonna
[ __ ] post over there you know me I
don't give a [ __ ] anyways what do I care
it's not like I'm posting anything
magnificent anyways right I mean I'm
just trying to show you the [ __ ] that
you need to see on Twitter
to be quite honest because
the new Twitter brings a whole new
meaning to the shitless Roundup doesn't
it like a whole new [ __ ] meeting to
the [ __ ] list Roundup so here I'll give
you a little background on the shitlist
Roundup and here's where it came from
for anyone who doesn't know this last
year
um we used to do this show just one day
a week it was on Wednesdays it was only
an hour and it's just me yapping which
is mostly what it is now
and then and then we would do guest
interviews and I would post those on
like a Friday so sometimes we'd have one
episode or two episodes a week
and then when Gabe Sanchez came on as uh
co-host and producer we we moved it to
where we did an interview every single
Wednesday and we did two hours
so we did a two hour show on Wednesday
and then after the first year we went to
every single weekday for two full hours
but here's the thing
I experimented with twitch this is why
I'm over there on Twitch all of you on
Twitch hello out there on Twitch
um I just I would do a live stream
every day and and I would just surf
Twitter that's what I would do on my
live stream I just it was informal and
there was no real you know
and it was haphazard I just literally
would start the stream and open up
Twitter and just start going through it
and commenting on the [ __ ] that I saw
I like that
the time I would do it and I would do it
you know sometimes three or four times a
week and then they got to where I was
doing it every day for about 30 minutes
or an hour or so and people would come
hang out and we would serve Twitter
together and we would comment we would
engage and then I started posting on
Twitter and then I started posting on
YouTube but then it became part of the
show when we did it every single day
so we changed our time from three
o'clock Eastern to noon
and then we did two hours every day and
that's where the [ __ ] list Roundup came
from now the name the [ __ ] list
came from when I was a kid and you did
something that you weren't supposed to
be doing
and you were in big [ __ ] trouble
my my parents would always say you're on
my [ __ ] list
you're on my [ __ ] list so I felt it very
very appropriate uh the content that we
were going through the people who were
on the [ __ ] list of democracy right you
know the Marjorie Taylor greens The Alex
Jones The Steve bannons the Donald
Trump's you know he's [ __ ] mcgaggers
some people are saying you just call
them maggots in the chat
um we came up with a thing yeah they
gaggers
which I mean that that that seems pretty
close right I mean that has a lot of
different meanings to it uh when you
call Trump supporter Gaggers but here's
the thing
is the content that we were going
through
uh was the [ __ ] that those were the
people on the [ __ ] list of democracy so
that's where the name came from and
that's the backstory of the shitless
Roundup
now I did not plan on Elon Musk
absolutely destroying Twitter and making
it a [ __ ] steaming pile of dung
but here we are and boy is the shitless
Roundup an appropriate name so let's do
this let's surf the Tweety tweets and
the trendy Trends while that some [ __ ]
is still running I think is it still
running I don't know I haven't checked
it in the last 30 minutes so maybe it's
down by now I don't know but let's let's
let's get to the [ __ ] let's Round Up
start the countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Tony Michaels
podcast Twitter is still running folks
we get to surf the Tweety tweets and
trendy Trends today because Twitter is
still operational
this is our title for today's space
Karen of course you know uh mate maybe
if you you need to go follow over on
Mastodon because if he does dig this
thing into the dirt over the next few
weeks we may have to go surf somewhere
else Mastodon or or Instagram or Tick
Tock we may have to go surf somewhere
else when we're doing the [ __ ] list here
um and for the show yeah and I don't
know we'll just we'll or managed though
there's always plenty of [ __ ] content
out there to absolutely mock and there's
plenty of ways for me to show you what
you need to see so that you are aware of
what these [ __ ] are doing
out there to our democracy
because there's plenty of [ __ ] to round
up today
um but the
the main news and I don't know Gabe
Sanchez surely will be joining us here
in just a few minutes and I know he
probably wants to talk about this and I
know we're going to talk about this in
the bonehead of the week
um because Elon gambling is going to
make an appearance on one of our uh
special categories
and we just wanted to guarantee that he
was on there
ah what a [ __ ] idiot space Karen did
you see the um did you see the
the side of Twitter they were projecting
on the side of Twitter you got to see
this [ __ ]
um they were actually projecting
um an image on the side of the Twitter
headquarters of course again the Twitter
headquarters is closed and the reason
why it's closed
um is because
Elon forget that he fired all the people
who could [ __ ] get him in the
building with the [ __ ] badges right
that's how they get in the building
their security they gotta scan in and it
opens the door but here is the Twitter
headquarters in as Gabe Sanchez says SF
and watch as the uh
the projection here on the side of the
building uh Supreme parasite
petulant pimple apartheid profiteer
dictators ass kisser well there you go a
lawless oligarch
insecure colonizer
and cruel hoarder
space Karen which is where the uh the
thumbnail comes from Renee mediocre
man-child
pressurized privileged Petty racist
megalomaniac I mean all these words are
are in in aimed to describe
um Elon Musk and to hurt his ego of
course that's really the story here I
believe right I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
that going here that's really the story
here
is that Elon Musk
is a
is a wannabe authoritarian right just
like Trump this is the same [ __ ] they
want to have power and they want to have
power over all people right
and they wanna they wanna put their
[ __ ] their [ __ ] selves right up in
your [ __ ] you ever met a person like in
a public place that like
like a close talker like they were in
your space
right
like just all up in your [ __ ] and really
we notice it more now after the pandemic
that they're so close but they just get
in your [ __ ] and they won't stay out of
your [ __ ] and it's not that you don't
really you know that you don't really
dislike this version or whatever it's
just man you're in my [ __ ] you're in my
[ __ ] but they want to be in everybody's
[ __ ] they want to tell you what to do
and who you can who you can and cannot
do what you can and cannot say this idea
that this [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ]
Elon Musk is for freedom of speech is
dumb this guy may have bought this app
just to scrub the pictures of him on
[ __ ] Twitter
I'm not [ __ ] you I really I really
believe that may be one of the things
that he's trying to do is suppress
stories about himself
and he could manage to handle it
uh when he didn't own Twitter
so his ego was so fragile these people
are snowflakes
he's such a [ __ ] snowflake the guy is
such a petulant child that he he is
setting policy for this this app
in the threads
someone's like hey Elon can you fix this
for me you know like an account called
cat turd it's like hey I want this and
he's like yeah no no problem cat turd
we'll do that making huge sweeping
decisions because an account called cat
turd said something it's really [ __ ]
dumb
but this is You Remember When Donald
Trump was the president of the United
States he'd do the same thing
his supporters would be clamoring on
about about people who are married to
certain people in the military
art oh people in the military have
certain genitalia and they're going to a
certain bathroom and he tweet he tweets
out a policy about it
and the whole world's like what in the
[ __ ]
that's what that's what's happening this
is what this is again this is a great
example of what happens when you let
authoritarians take over something that
is for and by the people
now again at Twitter the shareholders
were Rich folks that owned massive
shares and Twitter and they were able to
sell off their shares to Elon Musk we
are the shareholders of our democracy we
are
and we hold the power and the vote not
to sell it off to these [ __ ] idiots
to these authoritarians
that is what we have oh people were
asking earlier here's the uh here's the
here's the actual if I can make this
damn I don't know what's there I mean
there we go okay so here is here's the
the Mastodon server that I'm on
mstdn.social SO abbreviation of Mastodon
that's dot social there it is at the
Tony Michaels of course but again you
can go to the dooneymichaels.com and you
can find the
you can find the full link there so just
just go download the app again it's it's
a it's not a bad app I'm I'm not I'm not
gonna brag about it I mean I I really
I've only been on it for a few days I
just been experimenting with posting
over there and I appreciate anyone who's
followed me over there so if you if you
want to follow me just in case like
Twitter goes down over the weekend or
some [ __ ] I I'll still post over there
um if Twitter is down I'll post over
there like I do on Twitter sort of I
guess you know [ __ ] posting
um there is uh here is uh we know Kerry
Lake lost and there's gonna be some
Carrie Lake video that I want to show
you today if we have time we're gonna
get to the [ __ ] list round or the uh the
bonehead of the week here but here is uh
Carey Lake Carrie Lake uh posted this on
Instagram apparently uh I don't know if
you know who this is the whoosh
um Elena Abba and then uh Haba and then
Kerry Lake here
um and pager takes posted Kerry lake is
with Trump's lawyer Alina Haba at
presumably Mar-A-Lago it's hard to tell
but she was at Mar-A-Lago giving a
speech she's got this dress she's got on
I I don't know anything about fashion
I'm really ignorant of fashion but this
dress she's got on has curtains on the
front of it that when she's given her
speech I'm not [ __ ] you it's got
[ __ ] it's weird I don't I don't I
mean
immediately what I thought
when she came up on stage I'm like what
the [ __ ] is this the Hunger Games what
the hell is that the
it's weird I don't know I don't know
anything about fashion though so maybe
I'm way off maybe I'm just an [ __ ]
it's possible I'm being misogynistic and
an [ __ ] and toxic but I don't know
[ __ ] I don't know
um I said so Carrie carrieleg's legal
stat strategy is off to a shitty start
um when you're presumably hanging out
with lawyers like Haba and not a great
legal strategy for your your comeback on
your election there Gary because
apparently she's going to challenge all
this of course she challenged the whole
thing oh yeah she can challenge the
whole thing boo yeah I'm gonna chat the
whole thing and we're gonna win we're
gonna overturn the election not on this
election but the 2020 election hell we
just might overturn the 2012 election
and the 2008 election that way Barack
Obama was never president this is really
stupid [ __ ]
I mean this this election denialism is
[ __ ]
almost as ridiculous as the hunter Biden
laptop thing
almost as ridiculous and that's why I
say we need to treat the hunter Biden
lamb top thing the same way we treated
election denialism
we do not have to give demerits of them
talking about denying elections any kind
of [ __ ] debate we do not have to
debate these things
we don't have to debate the [ __ ]
made-up [ __ ] that that they're [ __ ]
lying about you don't have to debate
that stuff but what you do is you mock
them and you say do you really want
someone who is completely [ __ ] crazy
and a lunatic who believes this crazy
ass Hunter Biden laptop [ __ ] to be in
charge of anything that works that
narrative works so we can use
their delusion and their absolute
obsession with this Hunter Biden lamp
top thing to our advantage in 2024
because right now that's really what
it's about I mean there's a few
Governors races
um in 2023 that are that are going to be
crucial and important and I'm sure
there's going to be a few special
elections that are going to be important
kind of like the special election right
now down in Georgia that we need to
focus on Warnock
to make sure we get the 51 so we have
full subpoena power and we can cram
these judges down the throats
but there there'll be a few races in
2023 but 2024 is the mark folks that is
the most important election of our
democracy's lifetime now we're damn near
done counting we're damn near done
counting we're going to get to a lot of
certification uh of these votes which is
going to make it official we're going to
swear in now the new Congress
the the house and the Senate
a lot of these Governors are going to be
sworn in these secretaries of States uh
it's it's super important what you did
and the work you did for your democracy
to continue to do that work for 2024.
um and here's why we got new leadership
and we should be excited about this this
is Hakeem Jeffries
um
a Wu-Tang for children and post this on
Twitter uh did he do says Kevin McCarthy
and the GOP are the House GOP aren't
ready for the fire of Hakeem Jeffries
coming for them as the leader of the dim
house now some people are criticizing
that maybe he shouldn't be the leader or
something I don't know but listen I'm
excited about this [ __ ] being in
leadership now he's I think he's number
five
he's fifth in line in the leadership now
in the current uh house
so he's he's fifth so he's looking to be
the top spot jump jump up to the top
spot of course uh stinny Hoyer uh and um
uh Nancy close you're gonna take a back
seat so there's two there so he's
jumping up this guy's got fire under him
the other thing um about Hakeem Jeffries
that is super important he's in a very
safe District which is important for
leadership it's why
you see uh leaders whether it's house
leaders or democrat leaders all right
excuse me Republican or Democrat leaders
in the house especially but the Senate
as well is that they're in safe seats
you have to have a safe seat you can't
have your leadership losing their
[ __ ] election it undermines the whole
theory of them being a Democratic leader
or republican if you want to talk about
the fascist on the other side but Hakeem
Jeffries is in Brooklyn and Queens the
guy's in a safe district and because
he's a smart [ __ ] he's an
intelligent son of a [ __ ] he Nails it
on the head every single time the other
thing that I like about Hakeem Jeffries
that the Democrats need and that we we
received in some of these candidates in
the 2022 midterm in fetterman uh Tim
Ryan I know he lost but Tim Ryan uh Mark
Kelly uh Warnock and some of these other
uh candidates is that they are
interested in making sure that Democrats
put the [ __ ] gloves on for the
narrative they understand one thing
Hakeem Jeffries understands is [ __ ]
rhetoric
and I know that sounds great oh my God
Tony Jesus You're Gonna encourage
someone who knows rhetoric you goddamn
right I want to [ __ ] win I want
democracy to win here
how else are you going to win elections
if you don't have a national narrative
and drive it with rhetoric
I mean I know fake Gabe always like he
likes to use that word in the chat all
the time oh it's just rhetoric yeah you
goddamn write it is buddy hey fake Gabe
I'm glad you recognize that everything I
say is rhetoric I'm not I'm I'm not an
elected politician I'm not so everything
I say as a pundit or a talking head is
all rhetoric what the [ __ ] you think
this is I I don't have any control over
anything other than this microphone
I don't have control over anything it's
all rhetoric and that's the point
that is the actual point
and until we as a pro-democracy
coalition realize that we have to fight
the fight that is before us and I think
that's what we did in this these last
two elections 2020 and 2022 we realized
and there's a new generation coming up
that realizes that hey
the politics is the fun part
[ __ ] a policy and setting a
policy and determining what line items
and what bills that's a boring [ __ ]
let the smart [ __ ] figure that
out
hell we want to get we want to get down
in the trenches baby let's fight like
hell
that's what we want to do and the way
you do that is with national narrative
that's why you guys come here and listen
to me anyways yeah it's cathartic but
it's for you guys to communicate and
engage in that rhetoric and engage in
that National narrative that's the whole
[ __ ] point and until I get
um the the Democratic establishment to
realize that it's just going to be us at
this little party here but we're we're
getting uh bigger and bigger and bigger
here at the Tony Michaels podcast it's
getting more and more popular
the more people are seeing it more
people are coming and listening
and and and and
engaging in the rhetoric and the
national narrative uh whether they like
it or they don't like it I don't give a
[ __ ]
I really don't give a [ __ ] if you like
what I say or not I don't give two [ __ ]
I just like I believe Hakeem Jeffries is
am interested in advancing democracy and
I'm going to use what I know how which
is my voice to do that
and I'm going to advance the rhetoric of
a national narrative that liberalism is
not weak it is strong and it will fight
you to The Bitter End to save Liberty
that are afforded To Us by the rights
and freedoms of our constitution
and our Democratic constitutional
republic
and we will fight until the bitter
[ __ ] end and it's We're not gonna go
anywhere and that's that's the fire
that's the heat that Hakeem Jeffries
brings the other great part about
Hakeem Jeffries being in leadership
Nancy Pelosi is the first um female
speaker woman speaker in the history of
the House Representatives now King
Jeffries will be the first black man
and I I believe I know I know this feel
like well I mean Barack Obama but this
is significant
this is really significant
I I told you the other day that the one
thing that Nancy Pelosi has done for our
country more than just being the speaker
of the house or the congresswoman from
San Francisco
is she has helped diversify
the house
and that is important for our Congress
to look like our country that's what
representation is that's why these
[ __ ] white people are all mixed up
and all confused and pissed off anyways
is because they don't realize
the makeup of our country
they're insulated they're inside of an
echo chamber like Wendy Rogers Wendy
Rogers when a rascally rabbit uh Wendy
Rogers out in Arizona said
they're in an echo chamber and it's a
white supremacist Echo chamber that's
what this white Christian nationalism is
it's white supremacy
and they're really scared that they're
gonna lose their privilege which that's
not the case we just want everyone to
have the same exact privilege
and until we have our bodies of power
our institutions of power properly
representing the people in this country
then we are going to continue to have to
fight against this [ __ ] stupid idea
of white supremacy now it's not ever
going to go away
ideas don't die like fascism will never
die we just need to make sure we put a
check on it so it's not doesn't have the
range of power
to undo the progress that we've made
like Roe v Wade
so we have to stay vigilant here and to
do that we got to have rhetoric
I mean we gotta have a national
narrative to win elections that's you
goddamn right and listen to Hakeem
Jeffries here with the rhetoric and the
narrative listen so-called
GOP
Red Wave
turned into a red wedding for extreme
Mega Republicans and election deniers in
race after race after race all across
the country
has the Republican response the cult
leader should run again
and we're going to double and triple
down
on extremism we're going to double and
triple down on a nationwide abortion ban
we're going to double and triple down on
attacks on a democracy and we want to
eliminate Social Security
and Medicare that's extraordinary
but that is the modern day Republican
party as compared
to Democrats Who deliver big things for
the American people on the issues that
matter including around the economy job
creation lower cost and safer
communities
and there you have it that is why I
believe that Hakeem Jeffries is going to
be one of the greatest Democratic
leaders that we will have in our
generation
I truly believe that that this guy
understands the rhetoric he understands
the narrative he understands how
important those words are
and he's not choosing to be some kind of
[ __ ] intellectual Elite
where he's he's got a graph and he's
trying to show you statistics
and trying to get you to to be educated
about
the underpinnings of national democracy
and the statistics behind get the [ __ ]
out of here with that nonsense you do
not have to give someone a whole [ __ ]
library of numbers to understand what is
happening right out in the open
you don't
and he lays it out with the cult leader
he lays it out with the national Nair
the Red Wave [ __ ] turned into a red
wedding he lays it out perfectly
and he doesn't hesitate he doesn't stop
he doesn't quit he just pounds that drum
and that is the most important that is
the most important
of what we're talking about yeah see see
again uh you know I was talking
yesterday fake Gabe ah this see this is
exactly see vacate this is exactly what
I want you to do this is exactly what I
want you to do what the great
replacement theory was true you racist
[ __ ] you are a racist piece of
[ __ ]
I I love having fake game here he's so
easy like this is the Trump copy machine
Tucker Carl hey hey fake game tell us
tell us you listened to a bunch of white
supremacists without telling us you
listen to a bunch of white supremacists
you are a dumb [ __ ] you you you
really truly are a magaga a gagger a
maggot
you really are
again we know we know you're a white
supremacist we know you're a racist
we get it
we we know we know you're a [ __ ]
nincompoop Nazi
this is and this is exactly why I'm
excited I'm excited that they they're
not going to talk about inflation or gas
prices in This House of Representatives
that the Republicans are going to run
they're not going to do a [ __ ] thing
for fake Gabe on gas prices milk prices
inflation
they're gonna play into the stupid white
supremacy [ __ ] and fear Monger over a
laptop
and they're gonna tie it back to racism
every [ __ ] bit of it is going to be
that laptop trust me the laptop thing
even though it's a white dude that has
it they're gonna they're gonna rely on
racism
You're Gonna Hear China China China
China China China
laptop laptop laptop laptop laptop
coronavirus China virus China virus
China China virus laptop laptop laptop
that's what you're gonna hear
Muslims Muslims Muslims Muslims
Afghanistan Muslims Muslims Afghanistan
Muslims Muslims Muslims Afghanistan
that's what you're going to hear for the
next two [ __ ] years
and you're going to hear this white
supremacy [ __ ] like fake Gabe's doing
here folks they just lost an election on
that narrative
this [ __ ] that fake games typing in here
all the [ __ ] he types into this chat
they lost on every [ __ ] bit of that
[ __ ] that's that the [ __ ] he's typing in
here that he thinks he's got me oh I got
you I schooled you again that's what
made them lose in Pennsylvania Arizona
Michigan
Wisconsin they're going to lose in
Georgia over it
that's what made him lose
right there
so that's why I want you to keep coming
back fake Gabe you you you you are such
a [ __ ] nincompoop that you don't even
understand that's why we're excited
I'm not scared that Trump's running I'm
[ __ ] excited about it
they just [ __ ] lost
they [ __ ] lost the only reason why
they're keeping the house is because
they gerrymander the [ __ ] out of it
that's the only [ __ ] reason because
they cheated of course
of course they did
folks
this is a good sign of democracy
and the reason why is because the racist
the white supremacists out there you're
not going to change their minds like
fake Gabe he's such a [ __ ] simp he's
such a dumb [ __ ] he's gonna continue to
post this [ __ ] in the chat
just like [ __ ] Gaggers and [ __ ]
maggots are gonna continue to support
this trumpism [ __ ] yeah I get it it
feels like a lot of people it's a small
percentage and it is a lot of people
but listen let them keep losing
do not do not take the shovel out of
their hand why they are bearing their
digging their political grave don't take
the shovel out of the Nazis hands let
them dig this grave to bury themselves
in and fake Gabe does a great job every
day of digging a little deeper and
digging a little deeper and digging a
little deeper
and I like to pick on fake Gabe
but it it's not just him it's your Uncle
Earl it's your Aunt Edna on Facebook
it's the guy down the street that has
six tattered Trump Flags
that are in shreds and the one reason
why you can almost see through them
they're so transparent and the reason
why is because they were they were
printed in some [ __ ] cheap ass
Factory in China
and the and the [ __ ] [ __ ] inside
are like oh we need to get rid of trying
to kind of this trying to let China
virus see its Center Biden's laptop
and they have no clue no clue that the
flag's out front
the Six Flags Six tattered flags that
are almost invisible because the sun has
faded them so easily because they're so
cheap
is they're contributing to the problem
they say they want to stop
just like fake Gabe here you racist
piece of [ __ ] thanks for coming fake
Gabe thanks for showing us who you are
that's what these [ __ ] don't understand
this show we use sunlight as a
disinfectant okay let's uh let's move on
to a I get a good credit here
if you read it you give credit now let's
see what other video clip that I have I
want to show you a clip of um I think oh
yes oh yes here we go
here's more nonsense here's more
disinfectant that we need for sunlight
this is scary Lake after she lost she
has her filter still on but then let's
listen to what [ __ ] here has to say
here about the election that she lost
our election officials failed us
miserably what happened to arizonans on
Election Day is unforgivable tens of
thousands of Maricopa County voters were
disenfranchised now I am busy here
collecting evidence and data rest
assured I have assembled the best and
brightest legal team and we are
exploring every Avenue to correct the
many wrongs that have been done this
past week I'm doing everything in my
power to right these wrongs my resolve
to fight for you is higher than ever
I hope that Kerry Lake does not shut up
I know everyone wants her to go away I
do not want her to go away I hope she
continues to make these stupid videos I
hope she continues to go on Fox News oan
Newsmax I hope she continues to show up
in your [ __ ] feed
and the reason why is because she
literally is my pillowing her [ __ ]
election
and if anyone out there believes
that this is gonna go well for these
[ __ ] [ __ ] to do the my pillow guy
thing on these elections as if that's
going to be a winning message
you were not paying attention the last
[ __ ] two years you just were not
paying attention
I hope Carrie Lake never shuts the [ __ ]
up about this I hope she continues to
talk about this nonsense it is only
going to be so easy to tie Carey Lake to
every [ __ ] Republican anywhere
if you've gotten our next to your name
you're Carrie Lake
that's what you are that's who you are I
know Gabe Sanchez agrees to me there's
some point on this what do you think
Gabe Sanchez I'm I'm excited that Kerry
lake is never going to shut up about
this this is exciting yeah I mean I you
know I I covered it in a what was that I
talked about how they're going to double
down on this election denialism like you
might have people within the party that
push away from that because they see it
as a losing strategy but and just
because Trump didn't really talk about
it during his announcement speech
it's not going away it doesn't mean like
you don't just get rid of two years of
that narrative and have Carrie Lake push
push push Mike Lindell push push Mike
Flynn push Roger Stone push all of those
idiots push this idea that the election
was stolen you can't just get rid of
that you can't just up and go no no not
gonna happen anymore the other exciting
things are infatuated with this the
other exciting thing is is this picture
right here oh you're in Haba like oh my
God this is a this is my this is my my
fantasy that sh that habba could be her
attorney oh my God I mean it doesn't
make sense nothing better than Habit to
be carried there is no and let's just
let's just call out the obvious if there
was a case to prove there was voter
fraud widespread voter fraud across
Arizona or other states
there would be lawyers lining up imagine
if you were a lawyer and you could take
down the government on a case to say
boom We proved there was fraud but as we
know from 2020 it's all just a bunch of
goddamn theories there's no actual
evidence even when they were asked
multiple times Rusty Bowers asked Rudy
Giuliani they were like where's the
evidence where's the evidence where's
the evidence Rudy Giuliani said yeah
well it's coming we'll get it to you
Jenna else was like yeah we'll get it to
you and as soon as he's done farting on
me right and then Rudy Giuliana was like
well there are theories so we don't have
any evidence and they're like
what the [ __ ] have we just wasted our
time on the last how many ever months
trying to fight this thing between
November to January we've wasted so much
time
and they're going to keep doing it and
now they've started again we haven't
even finished the midterms we've got a
[ __ ] runoff in December right and
there's still a couple weeks yeah a
couple of accounts and so you look at
this and these people have not quit you
know they saw they literally saw in real
time for fake Gabe and all these other
people that election denialism does not
work we've seen it now democracy
actually wins in this debate if you want
to call the debate but it actually wins
in this type of fight right
it's more like a screaming match and we
just kind of scream and yell louder than
they are fake Gabe says here that's
right spew insults why facts are right
there you are you you re man literally
literally you guys are still believing
[ __ ] that is not true as it plays out
right in front of your face and I'm
happy that you're still believing this
nonsense yeah I'm happy I mean there is
a group within the Republican Party who
you know they gave it they gave it a try
right they were like yeah let's deny
deny deny we're really good at that
let's deny the 2020 election let's see
if we've got any sort of movement on
this
some people are like well it's over we
gotta call it and then other people like
no we're [ __ ] committed and that's
how we got the Insurrection on January
6th and some of those people
are like oh man I did a big boo-boo I
don't want to go to jail now and they're
crying when they're getting sentenced
which is hilarious uh and then you've
got the people that commit fully even
more Kerry Lake Alina Haba Christina Bob
you know Mike Flynn Mike Lindell Don Jr
even right uh I mean that might be just
more of an attempt for his dad to love
him but regardless at the end of the day
you've got these people who are [ __ ]
whacked out Q Anon Trump supporters
thinking that the the the storm is
coming
and Donald Trump is going to Reign Over
everyone and be reinstated
at some future date in the month of
neverary and so you know September 89th
I hear September 89th of 2030 never is
when he's going to be depressed and so
you know look fake Gabe over here
really just lost lost
so lost right now you know look I've
even tried to call fake Gabe on the
phone and consult him and console him on
the losses see if he'd show his face he
said he won't do it unless it's face to
face every time every time I say hey
fake game come on the show he goes no
face to face I call him doesn't answer
sends me right to voicemail and then in
the chat he says face to face yeah so
look yeah I'm just trying to help you
see the light that is a failing party in
election denialism and that goes for
everyone else that's in the mango party
right they are so [ __ ] committed just
like Elon is committed to tanking
Twitter you know well that's one thing I
want to get to here because um it is
kind of on fire over there we're in the
[ __ ] list round but let's do this
because I know how bad Gabe Sanchez
wants to absolutely talk about Elon Musk
so let's do this because we got I know
Elon I think it's three weeks in a row
now has made it three weeks yeah
mm-hmm Gabe Sanchez wanted to guarantee
he had this spot I wanted he was heating
up and now he's on fire oh my god well
man it it he has done a number over
there and Twitter so let's do this let's
take a break when we come back we'll get
to bonehead of the week everyone stick
around we'll be right back with bone end
of the week
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
come on Welcome Back to the show
[Music]
part of the show where we go over your
vote you vote you decide who is the
phone end of the week
in my co-host Gabe Sanchez break it down
every single Friday in the second hour
the Tony Michaels podcast bonehead of
the week
there you go there's the there's the art
for bonehead
uh everyone knows how bonehead works
here by now I would imagine but if you
don't know you must vote for bonehead of
the week you vote you decide who is the
bonehead of the week and we break it
down every single week so let's get into
it because we got a lot of I know Gabe
Sanchez is going to talk a lot about
Elon today I have a feeling I've got I I
even have a video
for Elon when we get to the Elon section
oh I've got a special video that I made
last night
oh and I think we'll
give everyone a bit of a laugh hopefully
okay well good well let's let's get into
it bonehead of the week foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of the week where you vote you decide
who is the bonehead of the week me and
my co-host of the Tony Michaels podcast
Gabe Sanchez break down your vote every
single Friday in the second hour of the
Tony Michaels podcast here on bonehead
of the week again if you're not aware
you can catch it every single Friday
Live on YouTube Twitter twitch
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page and our Facebook page at
the Tony Michaels and then we put a
shorter version on the Midas touch
Network every single Friday evening of
the bonehead a week you can also
download it
on Apple's modified Google
so make sure to subscribe here though to
the YouTube channel if you're watching
on YouTube and if you're not get your
ass over to YouTube and hit that
subscribe button that's where you can
vote on the community tab because who
the hell knows how long Twitter's gonna
be around as long as it's around it's
it's being held together by duct tape
and bailing twine right now have you
ever seen that commercial where it's the
infomercial the guy slaps the tape on
the huge like cylinder of water yeah
yeah yeah right that's pretty much
what's happening right now it's just
Elon like trying to plug holes with
random things and he's like oh hopefully
it doesn't crash you know well I know
elon's gonna be a big part of the
bonehead yeah but he was not on the
actual poll no and I think that's
because Gabe Sanchez wanted him to make
a third round of an appearance what can
I say special spot he's got a special
place in my heart
[ __ ] Elon okay here's here's the uh
candidates for bone end of the week
um reoccurring characters here it seems
uh representative Kevin McCarthy he's
really struggling to be the Speaker of
the House game Donald Trump also
struggling uh from his massive third big
loss here and then of course Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan let's go to
Kevin McCarthy first why not yeah why
not to Kevin McCarthy first do you think
he's going to be the speaker of the
house I don't think he's going to be I
don't think so I mean if he does it's by
a slim margin you know we've got people
like Marjorie Taylor green who said they
would vote for him in support obviously
to make sure that they investigate the
treatment of the jn6 insurrectionist but
then you've got Matt Gates you know
that's the the the decoupling the
divorce of America First really shows
yeah because they were kind of together
there for a couple days and then when
Marjorie turned on him
um he was a little upset it seemed and
Andy Biggs is also in the mix here right
I mean this is well you got Andy Biggs
Paul gosar a lot of these guys are
really pushing
um
they seem to be insurrectionist and on
that list is am I wrong on that it seems
like that's the trend
yeah no I mean it it there is a trend
it's a bunch of these denialists you
know insurrectionists Traders
um people that are okay with
with Russia um
you know supporting Russia not
supporting you they love Putin for sure
they love Putin oh they love that guy
here's these are all these are these are
the yeah I it's it's a minority of
people
and that are supporting
this America first but I I love the
infighting don't get me wrong the info
yeah like I am I got a bowl of popcorn
I'm eating away watching this drive that
wedge yeah hell to the yeah well see
here's Andy Biggs from Arizona
um and this is a tweet I think from this
morning or last night
um again it's unclear Twitter's kind of
um a mess over there but it says I've
seen enough
I cannot vote for Kevin McCarthy as
speaker in the house our house Speaker I
do not believe he will ever get the 218
votes and I refuse to assist in him in
his effort to get those votes so Andy
Biggs is not going to vote for him and
it seems that uh Paul gozar would follow
him also uh it seems like Matt gatz is
going to be on the same page uh as that
Marjorie Taylor green you know she kind
of did a deal where as long as Kevin
McCarthy lets her keep yelling and
screaming weird [ __ ] and do a microphone
about
um insurrectionist then and convicted
insurrectionist then she'll continue to
play that game right but Kevin McCarthy
is quite the dumb [ __ ] I mean he really
is this is yeah he's bone-headed uh as
bone-headed can get and the biggest
reason why here Gabe I feel like is that
he's letting his caucus go balls deep
into this Hunter Biden lamb top stuff
and I am all here for it literally I
want them to I want them to to tie the
entire
2024 campaign 200 Biden's laptop like
the entirety of well maybe a little bit
on the election of denialism and then
and then the rest of it Hunter Biden's
Lifetime well I really truly believe
that this is going to be quite the
losing strategy and I mean it also shows
you how desperate Kevin McCarthy is
right like he's got no platform
uh you know when the when the comparison
was made during the midterms of like
this whole like well both parties are
the same you know or like this different
sides the same coin type of [ __ ]
it's like no one side is actively
working to protect your rights and the
other side is actively working to take
them away and you saw that almost
immediately after in terms of the bills
that have been worked on right same-sex
interracial marriage like why wouldn't
we codify that that seems [ __ ] I
don't know a no-brainer but then you've
got you know Republicans in the Senate
who are like
nope not for that Mitch McConnell who's
literally in his own interracial
marriage with Elaine Chao
the same goes for the house you've got
these people that don't have a strategy
their only platform is to own the libs
and Kevin McCarthy is desperate to use
Hunter Biden's laptop uh Jan six
insurrectionist you know he's trying to
appease as many people as he can to whip
up these votes to support him and I
think it's like if he gets it it's gonna
be by the [ __ ] bare minimum like a
hair if he gets it
but I also think that remember he's got
to get 218. so his own party is having
issues with
collecting themselves around the same
message the same strategy some people
want to do this some people want to live
in the past some people want to move on
he's going to have a hard time and I I
honestly don't think he's going to get
it but if he does so who gets 218. who
gets 218. well who else is the who's the
alternative in that party well I mean
Jesus Christ you think Andy Biggs is
going to get 218. oh no not at all
you've gotta you've gotta I mean like it
does come down to like
people in that party trying to figure
out like oh is this better or worse than
like Akeem Jeffries being speaker right
or like having a any Democrat being well
like it really comes down to that like
what are they willing to compromise or
sacrifice and we we've kind of went over
this Theory because it doesn't have to
be a sitting member of Congress right it
does not have to this there is nothing
in our
in in the body of the House of
Representatives that dictates that the
speaker of the house has to hold the
seat
um they're just the presiding officer of
of the the House of Representatives now
some have said that like Liz Cheney
could you know and get a coalition of
the majority of Democrats and possibly
handfuls of Republicans right to get the
vote on the floor and she could get to
218. I think that's kind of crazy to
think that that would even be a
possibility it's fun to think about it's
fun to talk about you know because I I
would believe that it would [ __ ] in
their cereal but actually what I believe
is is that if we really want to
um suggest that the crazy is going to
well having the crazy red out in the
open is going to save our democracy
because people are going to realize what
these people's motivations are then
maybe we should have one of the other
boneheads
um BS I don't think he could get 218
either but no Jim Jordan is you talk
about you talk about an Elon type I mean
this [ __ ] would absolutely
destroy the Republican Party probably
faster than Elon destroyed Twitter
literally I think Jim Jordan would tear
it all down in moments like just [ __ ]
well I mean you gotta you got it put on
a jacket well Jim Jordan you know how
many years has he been in uh Ohio rep he
has not
passed any legislation what a question
the real question is how how long has he
not said anything about the student
athletes that he was witnessing uh being
sexually molested that's that's probably
because I always call him Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan because right
that's truly the craziest part about Jim
Jordan is that he is absolutely obsessed
obsessed
with Hunter Biden's laptop just obsessed
with it he's he goes all the way back to
2015 on Hunter Biden's laptop but the
guy couldn't muster up enough courage to
protect the students at his university
get the [ __ ] like what makes you think
he's going to protect you students
children families whoever he's not going
to do a goddamn thing because the guy
has no courage no right like I said he
could barely put on a jacket I've never
seen him with the jacket on I've never
seen him pass legislation I've never
seen him actually come forward and
propose something of value and Merit the
guy complains and complains coins he's
the person you put in charge if you
really want to [ __ ] the bed and you're
like look we need to like spend as much
money as we can right by the end of the
quarter
yeah like that is the person you know on
par with you know Elon in terms of of
Twitter Yvonne should hire him to be his
uh his his his uh head of security and
safety this guy
quite possible I mean look
Jim Jordan or Kevin McCarthy whoever's
the face of the GOP in the house like
either way it's pretty pretty sad pretty
pathetic it's pretty lame because every
one of these people they don't care
about who you are they don't care about
what you need they only care about
themselves I mean they talk about your
problems but they don't want to do
anything well they talk about your
problems as if it's their own but you've
got a person who has a six-figure salary
uh amazing Health Care great benefits
Transportation Security all the power in
the world right a lot of power you know
in turn
the ability to take money from lobbyists
like
there is so much that these people
use
and take advantage of you and then use
and yeah use and abuse and throw you off
to the side when they're done with you
right that's the story that's the story
of it but let's listen this is from this
morning on um uh Trader News Network FOX
business
um let's just listen to what he says
it's probably really stupid it is Jim
Jordan connecting the dots to a national
national security threat to America
because that's in my view what's most
important here it's not about attacking
a sitting president's family it's about
what this represents with regard to
communist China and other adversaries
can you connect those dots
yeah it seems like he's doing business
deals in all kinds of countries that are
adversaries to the United States it's
Ukraine it's uh well Ukraine's on
atmosphere but at the time it's a
corrupt kind of kind of place oh my God
over there but but Russia and China
um and and of course remember how this
story has changed when we pointed this
out yesterday at first when this came
out two years ago oh no no it's not it's
not Hunter Biden's laptop
and then it was well okay it's his
laptop maybe it's really not Russian
disinformation but President Biden
wasn't involved remember he said I have
no knowledge of my son's business
dealings it's a show them okay so I
wanna I wanna give you some context here
to the audience of of these two
boneheads talking about this [ __ ]
literally a sitting president of the
United States daughter who was part of
the administration
received trademarks from China
you dumb [ __ ] money I mean
trademarks are [ __ ] value you stupid
[ __ ] you really and I know
laptop but here's the thing
literally a sitting president of the
United States and Donald Trump who put
his daughter and son-in-law in the
[ __ ] white house with official
government positions when they couldn't
do the background check and he overrode
that she [ __ ] took valuable
trademarks from China wow they were
[ __ ] in the administration you stupid
[ __ ] you dumb there is no Hunter
Biden's laptop this is the stupidest
[ __ ] thing I've ever heard of in my
life and we need to keep mocking them
for this and you know what we do we just
do what I just did we point out that
they're projecting just like just like
when they're doing election denial
they're saying we're cheating because
they want to cheat to win that's how
they got the house anyways as they
gerrymander that [ __ ] right I
mean again it's a party with no platform
no no actual beliefs that they'll help
you they take away anything you have and
take advantage of things that you have
they strip and deplete the resources
that you might have like these are
there's people that don't care and then
of course when it comes to like well you
know
there's an example of Ivanka or there's
an example of Jared or there's yeah I
mean yeah and they and they go what are
you talking about that's normal business
that's A-Okay and you're like wait but
you literally just called this out
a son of a sitting president
who doesn't work for him who doesn't
have a position in the white house
administration who by the way didn't do
any of this stuff that you're claiming
wow Joe Biden was President of the
United States I mean it goes the same
same [ __ ] when it comes to taking
the dot classified documents out of
Mar-A-Lago what about the servers
Hillary Clinton they didn't they didn't
have to come in Obama has a library
right what Bill Clinton Bill Clinton has
socks in his drawer or something they're
like all of these documents are held in
the in the Chinese laundromat and like
what are you talking about it's always
it's it literally it literally is always
something to do with China
and it only
and believe that that Don Jr Eric Ivanka
Jared Trump all these [ __ ]
Republicans have so much invested in
China that it's not even funny like
that's what it makes because it's all
projection in the first place but what
else am I supposed to assume how awesome
am I supposed to I mean just just here
there's a there's a good way that I
approach this if a republican makes a
claim there is always either a tweet
or some vote
or something they've said in the past or
some clip of them that is the complete
opposite or some receipts of them you
know being like I'm
against abortion and then pain for
multiple abortions right there any one
of those things I guarantee if you look
at any of these people who are in office
or running for office they say something
and then you see the complete
contradiction on the other end of them
doing the that that same thing that
they've they've condemned right that
they've said don't do this thing I don't
believe in it and then they themselves
are the ones who are doing it well
speaking of that that brings up another
member of Congress that made a special
appearance here on the bonehead of the
week now she's actually the alpha cook
um and she got she got Alpha cooked by
Kevin McCarthy right I think that's why
she made the list but I got a clip here
that I love this show of an example of
what just you were talking about with
this [ __ ] bonehead this out the alpha
cut of the week but she got Alpha cut
and here's what happened she was with
the Matt Getz side and the Andy Biggs
podcasting together holding hands
America First and with Nick Fuentes
listen
she turned on a dime when she realized
that she could do a deal to continue a
bunch of nonsense into a microphone so
that's what she did and also also the
other thing that she did is she realized
that if they don't get one of their own
it could be an outlier that gets this
218 meaning someone that these these
Trump these magagas these Gaggers these
maggots right these trumpletites don't
want could be the speaker and that's
their worst [ __ ] nightmare is when
they start selecting committees and Jim
Jordan in charge they don't get the
hunter buying investigations that they
want they don't get the fentanyl
investigations that they want that's
what this clip is about this is a
beautiful
beautiful 51 seconds here
of of this bonehead we've had Texas Paul
on several times talking about fentanyl
coming across the border right yep and
Texas Paul several times has brought up
the Cato Institute they are they are
definitely right-wing they are their aim
is for right right-wing [ __ ] in this
country they are right wing Institute if
you want to call them that but they're
actually doing research about facts of
what's coming across the border with the
Fentanyl and who's bringing it across
this is [ __ ] the weirdest [ __ ] I have
ever seen that someone who wants to be
in leadership and member of committee
who definitely wants to be a contender
for vice president under Trump in 2024
literally say [ __ ] the Cato Institute
watch this [ __ ] oh yeah yes a quick
question a lot of you mentioned uh
that's the federal crisis that has
happened the most then they'll come from
people across the border for United
States citizens not necessarily
immigrants
so the reporter there says hey
in in the grand scheme of things when
you look at the data
because what they do is when they stop
someone with fentanyl they record
who had it
and they're saying that look
the fentanyl that's coming across the
border is not from immigrants it is from
United States citizens that go to Mexico
get the Fentanyl and bring it back
across the border through the gates not
over a fence or through a river
through the gates so let's see Marjorie
Taylor Green's response it's it's
beautiful
uh what is your response to that uh
I would ask for where's your proof on
that because that's not what we've been
shown that's not what when we go to the
border and we're speaking with border
patrol agents uh when we're there on the
ground that is not at all what we're
being told so I'm going to push back on
your I'm sorry I don't see
um of course the the reporter says
here's the evidence here's the craziest
part about it all the Cato Institute
right how they get their data and how
they're mashing up their data to show to
show their report they get it from a
place uh what's that that that [ __ ]
Federal agency that protects the Border
I think she just said it it was border
patrol is that it it's it's Insanity
yeah it's Insanity that she's like we
went down to the border and there was
one racist border patrol agent that
totals it was brown people bringing
fentanyl into this country well whenever
they go down to the Border they're
always doing some [ __ ] faux photo
shoot right you've got Ted Cruz and
Lindsey Graham looking through the weeds
of the Rio Grande and getting on a
[ __ ] duck boat [ __ ] and they're
driving around me like you know which by
the way they're getting mocked I think
what I remember they were getting mocked
by Coyotes across the river right
um but anytime they're going on the
border they're not actually doing
anything they do a tour they go like oh
yeah okay and they're not gonna bring
border patrol agents that have any kind
of Tethered to reality they're gonna
bring the ones that they want it that
they're gonna and here's the thing that
they want to hear this is the classic
[ __ ] of show me proof and the person
says all right here's the receipts
here's the proof and they go well that's
not what we were told by someone okay
right one you're a patrol agent that we
made sure that was a that was there with
us right we knew would say the [ __ ] that
we wanted to hear said the [ __ ] we
wanted to hear well so that person could
have not even said any of that and they
just thought it like Trump just like
thinking that he just Declassified
documents Marjorie Taylor green was like
she was like I I woke up in a in a dream
and I was talking to a border patrol
agent and he told me how much he hates
brown people and and all these brown
people are bringing fentanyl across the
country and giving it to kids for free
on Halloween and all this fentanyl like
how many cases did they have of that how
many how many what cases were there of
fentanyl being passed out of Halloween
do have we have we got a is how many
thousands currently doing a recount
because right now we came up with zero
but we're gonna go through county by
county to figure out exactly what's
happening they said no one recounts no
one gave out fentanyl is what you're
they said yeah well right now you mean
that was all [ __ ] you mean that was
all [ __ ] [ __ ] Tony I support a
recount I wonder if Hunter Biden's
laptop [ __ ] is real I wonder if that
shit's real I wonder if the media should
take that seriously like they took the
like they took the Halloween fentanyl
story seriously Jesus I kind of want to
make a character yeah uh I don't want to
say it on the air oh yeah don't say it
don't some [ __ ] steal it let's
listen let's listen to how how Marjorie
Taylor green
um
absolutely says the Cato Institute
doesn't know what they're talking about
which if anything the Cato Institute
should be on is on her side but let's
listen
um
the Cato Institute is not the border
patrol there's a big difference there
I'm sorry is the Cato down there
securing our border and stopping illegal
aliens and human trafficking and drug
trafficking I'm sorry you're gonna have
to get a direct source and when you
bring the border patrol in here and want
to quote that then then we may take you
seriously but we're not we're not taking
again the Cato Institute what they do is
they get data from a government agency
that government agency is the [ __ ]
border patrol literally the the data
that the [ __ ] Cato Institute is
reporting on and giving their their
analysis of is the data they receive
from the government agency that is
border patrol literally it is border
patrol [ __ ] data and again we've had
Texas pollen several times and as right
wing as the Cato Institute is they are
going through that data and they are
being honest about that data there is
not a single shred of evidence in the
border patrol data that suggests that
the majority of fentanyl that is coming
into our country is being across the
Mexican border yeah is being carried by
by migrants it is all coming from United
States citizens that go because people
in the United States can go to Mexico
very easily they they can get into
Mexico they do it all the time like
people on the border like hey let's go
eat food in Mexico we're gonna get in
our car and we're gonna drive through a
gate and we're gonna go eat and then
when we're done eating we're gonna pick
up some [ __ ] Fentanyl and we're gonna
drive it back because Chad has some
cooking to do down the street it really
is [ __ ] stupid that people don't
realize that you can go into Mexico
right I mean it's not a big wall that
you can't get across it's just like the
[ __ ] uh no I know well here's the thing
it is almost the exact same when it
comes to oh these illegals coming across
the border look if you really broke down
the people who are here illegally you
know
one of those people is Elon Musk at the
time uh
in here illegally because they
overstayed their Visa or they came to
visit and they never left and they're
here that way but coming across the
border you're not having a caravan of
people if there was a caravan it's
literally on a 757 flying into into
[ __ ] Newark or JFK and then from
there those people say great I'm in the
land of America the Earth I'm in America
the land of opportunity and they set up
camp and they go and they never go away
and they ever leave right which I'm not
against I'm really not against I if as
long as you're a productive member of
society oh I think you should be here
but this this idea that even the
majority of fentanyl comes across the
border is so stupid we talked about this
with Texas Paul the majority of fentanyl
comes through [ __ ] postal services in
particular the United States Postal
Service from China in little bitty
[ __ ] containers it's and they dilute
it down and Chad's shed that's what
happens
and we we've explained this a million
times and the the craziest part about
what [ __ ] Marjorie Taylor green is
saying here is that Joe Biden is failing
at the border because they're not
catching the fentanyl but the people
that she says is the experts are the
people catching the fentanyl as the
migrants are coming across the border so
which is it which is it you [ __ ] you
bone-headed Alpha cuck so there you go
there's Marjorie Taylor green is the
alpha cook
um Gabe now I know you want to spend a
lot of time on this guy the next one
yeah
I'm literally I literally am about to
I'm like on my phone at the same time
trying to post this to Twitter oh are
you oh now my phone is doing speak to uh
Speech to Text hitting a button hitting
a button I know yeah you're screwing it
up but uh this guy this is his third
week in a row yeah dude he's on fire
like literally oh he was heating up last
week and this week he's on fire uh where
do we even start with this [ __ ]
bonehead
um and I know you want to spend some
time on this because we know who the
winner of the bonehead of the week is
yeah who thinks he can he can make
losing great again
um and we'll spend you know 10 minutes
on that and that's pretty easy but this
Twitter thing is absolutely insane and I
know a lot of people don't like the
Twitter talk and what does it have to do
with democracy but I said in the first
30 minutes in the a block in my rant
that look this is an example
of what happens when you give a really
stupid authoritarian rule over something
this is the perfect example of it of how
you can go from a somewhat Democratic
institution meaning they have board
members they have shareholders they have
they have administrative offices and
Executive offices they have people down
below them that that have different
tasks in different departments like it
is a huge huge bureaucracy at Twitter
yeah right and there's a global company
right this is an example of what happens
when you put an absolute dumb book in
complete charge of it now again I want
to say that Elon Musk
is the authoritarian in this example and
the shareholders
are the the voters in this example
with our democracy the good news is is
we are the shareholders of our democracy
and I believe that we will not sell out
our democracy I think you proved that
once again we proved that once again in
the 2022 midterm and I believe we will
prove that even more in the 2024 a
general election I think we're going to
do that
um but in this case the shareholders
decided yeah we'll sell out our their
quote democracy or their bureaucracy of
Twitter to Elon Musk to an authoritarian
and within weeks within weeks this thing
is running on on [ __ ] duct tape and
bailing twine like literally what is
[ __ ] holding because their
headquarters is absolutely closed right
uh yeah it's closed till Monday so they
shut down last night shut off card
access to people they are not he was
calling and begging the guy he was in
charge of the car so it turns out so
that one it turns out that tweet well
there is some truth to it uh that tweet
was big that guy is a parody account
oh so that's not see this is this is the
this is yeah buddy so did Elon did Elon
buy it that it that it was a real
account uh because he tweeted it I know
he was like oh thanks you're a lifesaver
I think he realized it was a joke and so
he like went into it but again like the
guy's trying to save face and be like I
totally meant for this all to happen
right yeah right okay and it's like
whether your plan was to toss away 44
billion dollars worth of loans and Saudi
money and other investors like doesn't
yeah but he's not just throwing this
away he has to pay this back because oh
yeah he personally took these loans
right this is him he bought this all
these shares from these shareholders it
he has to pay I mean last person you
probably want to [ __ ] owe money to is
a bunch of Saudis I mean right you know
I just I mean that's it's just one of
those things like yeah yeah but let's
let's get back to because here's I think
a lot of people are concerned about this
because a lot of people are like is this
thing even going to be [ __ ] running
when we wake up in the morning they're
really concerned yesterday because not
only did he shut down the headquarters
um I think all the support team is gone
and I think he has less than 200
employees they have no payroll
department
um I think I think there's no there's no
payroll department there's no U.S tax
team right so what's going to happen is
he's going to have to bring in
contractors to work on payroll because I
don't know about other states but I know
California there are some big fines you
have to pay if you're not paying people
on time if anything's screwed up like
employees consume so he's gonna have to
have like uh I I mean and to throw a big
name after like a quick books type yeah
he's gonna come in and run he's
basically have to hire a third party to
be his payroll department right right
they're just gonna cost you more money
in the long exactly because not only
that but you've laid people off so now
now those payroll people have to confer
with whoever's left in HR to then say
hey can we verify that these people are
still employed if not like we need to
they're going to go through like this
weekend is probably a full-on audit of
people that still work there or don't
work there uh access amongst different
things people that they did fire or left
that they might try to get back like
they did the first round of layoffs when
they did 50 of the people that were let
off it's just
insane the amount of just [ __ ] that's
hitting the fan every single day it's
something new
and you're like can he do worse yes he
can and it's amazing honestly well you
know and this meme kind of sums it up
I'm gonna need you to pretend I didn't
run this app because here's the thing I
believe Twitter's not gonna go anywhere
right like yeah it's just gonna be not
what you think it was going to be it
it's going to be completely different
than it was four weeks ago it's not
gonna be the same animal like even this
morning I was telling the audience
earlier and I think I sent you a couple
examples
um in in in text messages that uh that
my home feed was already packing for
what looked like Han and four Chan [ __ ]
in other words it's already
he's already [ __ ] with something there
to start feeding this garbage back into
um The Fray which that that is going to
probably be the the ultimate thing that
kills Twitter because what I don't
really quite understand and again I gave
Elon too much credit is
the purchase and we've talked about the
support the purchase of Twitter the
reason why it was significant is because
it's one of the largest user bases in
the entire world like it already exists
so in other words there's a huge list of
users
237 million daily active users those are
people that log in and are on they don't
have to interact but they've at least
logged in which is probably and it's
probably in the top five of the biggest
user bases is that yeah I mean I believe
the top five remember that Twitter is a
huge Communications tool for uh
movements activists governments oh [ __ ]
we built it we built this we built this
podcast
um the way it is right now in Twitter
DMS me and you we basically use Twitter
DMS to build this this show I mean it is
a huge huge organizing communication
tool yeah but here's the thing
if the idea is to overpay by 20 maybe 30
billion dollars for the biggest user
base and then what you do is you
absolutely [ __ ] on the bureaucracy right
that the employees that hold that
[ __ ] user base together because that
truly is what he is missing here and
Elon just he's not capable of
understanding I don't know like empathy
um you know it just it doesn't have it
with him and the reason why I know he
doesn't is because he fully doesn't
understand that it's Twitter
not just the company but also the user
base is people like these are [ __ ]
people and he doesn't he doesn't quite
have enough empathy to understand that
the app isn't about advertising yeah the
app isn't about who owns it the app
isn't about who buys what blue check
mark and who doesn't the app is about
people and he he does not understand
that and that is why it looks like he's
burning it to the ground because Jack
Dorsey understood it the Twitter
employees understood it
um the users I think the majority of
users in the world understood that the
app is about the people on that because
without the people on the app it's
nothing if he loses two-thirds of his
user base of his active users because he
makes it an uh just another [ __ ]
carbon copy of getter uh of true social
a parlor of 4chan of Han he it's not
gonna work and what I mean by that is
he's not going to be able to make it
worth 44 billion it's just no he's the
the value of Twitter like you know I
think it was somewhere in like the 20
billion or so range is what it really
was worth in terms of like the market
value at the time less than 30 billion
he paid over like 30 some odd 40 over 54
20 was this was the strike price that he
he offered which put it which put it at
44 billion he overpaid for a company by
billions by almost 2x okay
the company right now I mean if you were
to sell the intellectual property and
assets and because they have a lot of
them yeah yeah I mean like not only like
the real estate if they own those I
don't know if they own the Twitter HQ
that's on Market Street but they might
just be renting out multiple floors
that's the one that had the projection
up on it last night yeah yeah that's
when it has a projection so uh yeah I
used to go there all the time because I
had buddies who worked at Twitter right
I mean they no longer work at Twitter
some left because anyone work at Twitter
well you there's there's less than 200.
there were people that were I think the
the number was like 238 yeah but how
reliable is that number right so you
have to like the thing that I cannot say
enough about is the fact of how glad and
how proud I am of those employees being
like nope [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm calling
your bluff I'm not gonna I'm your
ultimatum is [ __ ] I'm going to quit
and I'm going to take the two-month pay
plus the one month Severance that's
three months of pay I'm out
and I don't think Elon was expecting
that I think Elon was assuming that if
he push people hard enough and gave them
some sort of incentive which to him the
incentive was like if you work hard
enough you could be here around for
Twitter 2.0 but I'm gonna challenge you
you're gonna work hard you're gonna work
long hours you're going to sleep in the
office all of these things all of these
things he was not using as an incentive
but they were a deterrent to be like why
would I work in this [ __ ] toxic
workplace
like I've worked in talks of workplaces
in SF when I was working for startups
and and on toxic and podcasts too you
know right yeah yeah
and and I know what it's like to work
those conditions you know I wish when I
was younger I would have known to be
like no I shouldn't work here at this
place or I I would have known when to
say
this is my time I need to go take to go
do something else I honestly when I'm
younger I'm gonna be like yeah I'll do
it I'll do whatever I'll work longer
I'll do this I'll do this like it's the
whole [ __ ] like startup and grind
work hard hustle [ __ ] all of that
stuff it's a terrible oh I've done that
my whole life done that my whole life
but then you see the American dream
right and I'll say this you see yeah
that is the American dream except
exploitation of Labor Is Not The
American Dream well and I think that's I
think that's a good point and that's the
clip I want to show you here is because
I think this idea that that the new
generation that's coming up especially
this one that's heavily engaged in in
their country and in their system of
government and and they're interested in
the policy changes that that their
engagement in their democracy can bring
that gen Z is gonna put up with this
idea that you have to work 80 hours a
week to be successful that's really
stupid look success is not the same Mark
for everyone in this country some people
just want to make a decent wage they
want to love what they do for work they
they don't want to have to work their
asses off they do want to have family
time they do want to have personal time
so their mental health doesn't get
driven into the [ __ ] dirt but listen
to this this morning
this is in Hollywood Florida I guess
um they're talking about Elon Musk and
I'm not sure who the uh
um the the lady in the black dress or
the blonde hair is here I don't know one
of the countless other people who with
blonde hair they all look the same don't
they like yes these I mean there there
is a there is a graphic online that I've
seen where it shows all of the Fox News
correspondence over time in the last x
amount of years and they're all
female blonde hair look the same you
could not pick them up or like pick them
out through a lineup
oh you could pick them up let's listen
let's listen to the um let's listen to
what she says about
it's just the it's I can't even believe
they're gonna say something and I'm
gonna say why it's dumb how tone deaf
they are to what the reality of
Americans are even after we have been
through a pandemic and the whole you
know some people are are are mandatory
working some are let's watch hard do you
want to stay are you not going to censor
people because if you want to follow my
rules then you can stay if not I'll pay
you for three months and you can go so
he's not like picking and choosing who
he's firing he's saying you choose he is
and okay so so the host there is saying
that Elon Musk said the choice which is
yeah sure absolutely he did yeah now I
do want to say though I do want to say
though that like you said earlier he's
the [ __ ] that thought that they would
be like
yeah I'm gonna well just like just like
all the anti-baxters out there yeah when
employers were like Hey we're going to
require you get the vaccine because we
want our employees to be healthy and
they're like oh No One's Gonna Take it
and everyone pretty much took it yeah
besides the [ __ ] boneheads and you
know I I can't speak for the people who
are left at Twitter but ah you've seen
kind of boneheaded but let's listen to
her response here to this idea he is and
he's draining the swamp of Twitter and
it needs to be drained but the way that
he's doing it to me is genius he's
saying I want people that want to work
here and they have some Integrity that
want to work hard and that should be the
standard and the fact that we've moved
so far away from that then now we're
having headlines about him sending out a
memo saying I expect you to work
extremely hard that should be the
standard for every job and every young
person and young people need to
understand it's not all about six months
vacation being an influencer having a
work-life balance it's not working hard
and if you want to work somewhere like
Twitter you're gonna have to work hard
and you're gonna have to treat people
fairly and if that's too much hey
there's the door
okay this is Boomer okay boomer this is
the dumbest
[ __ ] I've ever heard when I see people
on Twitter that go and also I you know I
criticized uh Elon when he was doing his
initial layoff saying that he was you
know forcing people to work 12 to 14
hours to prove their worth and their
value to build this Twitter verification
tool for uh that was a flop uh and that
ended up just biting him right in the
[ __ ] ass
but when I called him out and I was like
look these people are not guaranteed the
safety of their job even by putting in
the 12 to 14 hours to build this thing
that he made an arbitrary deadline for
and then he let people go you're not
establishing trust in your company then
after people are laid off and some
people leave and whatever
because again it's their choice
uh obviously if you're going to be smart
about it you hold off and see if you can
get more money out of it or you can get
some money out of it
but Elon right now says you got a choice
you either you got to click this button
yes I plan to stick around or no I plan
to resign if you don't answer the email
we take it as a resignation which is
kind of [ __ ] up uh I mean he's already
being sued by someone who's a cancer
survivor who has to work from home based
on their health situation
so he's in a lot of trouble right now
but
right now I see a ton of people a ton of
people [ __ ] attacked me for calling
him out for asking people or not asking
but having forcing people to work 12 to
14 hour days and people said I work
three job 12 hours days raised four kids
I'm like again you want that for other
people you you went through that so you
want that for your kids you want that
for your grandkids you want that for
other people I thought the whole goal
was as Generations we were supposed to
make lives for those who follow us
easier or better well but and this is
the challenge that we have right
and and it's this is that each
generation
um has gotten better and had more handed
to them yeah um and didn't have to quote
as she said work hard for what they had
um
and as that continues you you begin to
uh hang on to your privilege like some
in this country are and that's sort of
the problem that we have and again
that's why I say Elon Musk buying
Twitter and destroying it within a
matter of weeks is the absolute [ __ ]
prime example of why you do not give an
authoritarian especially one that is
dumber than dog [ __ ] any kind of power
when you do that they [ __ ] destroy
authoritarians destroy [ __ ] they do not
build it and make it great they destroy
[ __ ] I mean just like Elon Musk
absolutely is not going to be the top
tier with Tesla in in EVS they are not
they're not gonna be and and it's
becoming more and more clear why it's
because of him it's because of him and
the only reason why Tesla even can
manage to to be in a market for EVS is
because they're publicly traded if they
were not publicly traded Tesla would
would not even be a [ __ ] company
right now probably right there's
probably no way that Elon would be able
to manage to [ __ ] hang on to Tesla
with his technology of EVS because folks
in the next two years in the next four
years there's gonna be more EVS that are
way more advanced way better and much
better price point than Elon could ever
dream about a Tesla no one gives a [ __ ]
about the autonomy they don't give a
[ __ ] it's clear that there is that there
may be a market for um the autonomy of
vehicles but it's not there yet it is
more about I mean Jesus Christ these
Republicans yelling scream about gas
prices for two years now and and
everyone thinks that the market is for
autonomy it's not it's for the [ __ ]
the price of the use of your vehicle
that is the idea and I believe that Elon
Musk is not only going to bury Twitter
here and and again Twitter will live it
just won't be what it is and it's going
to lose a lot of value but he's going to
probably bury Tesla and definitely
SpaceX I think which is kind of sad
because of some of the technologies that
the actual people again people at those
companies these companies are people and
that they're developing it's kind of sad
but yeah and again you know you've got
these people on Twitter who'll be like
oh man I would love to work for Elon
Musk and I would I would work those
hours and do that [ __ ] okay fine I
guarantee one you do not have the skill
set to go to Twitter two if you did have
the skill set I guarantee you would not
last more than I'll give you two weeks
it would not last more than two weeks
probably a week based on the hours and
based on the requirements and based on
what is being asked of you
yeah you go in there and I especially
whoever that woman is if she wants to go
and work for Twitter
by all means go do it if you're gonna if
you're gonna call and like talk a big
game then you better be able to back it
up and do it yourself because it's very
easy for people to be like oh I would
totally do that if I could oh yeah those
hours aren't an issue if you don't work
hard then what's the point you lazy
piece of [ __ ] okay go do it then go do
it and I guarantee that the woman that's
on the panel right there this is a
Morning Show so she wakes up early yeah
has to go through hair and makeup done
for her wardrobe done for her she's told
what to say done for her
she's done within a few hours and then
the rest of the day she's doing
something else all right she's got are
you assisting that political pundits
don't work hard because I'm starting to
be offended but I'm just I'm not saying
all political comments don't work I'm
just I'm just getting that I'm just
political part I'm just kidding Let's
want to say hard work is I I think
there's all sorts of definitions slave
labor I think there's all sorts of
definitions of hard work but I believe
that everyone who works hard deserves to
have their time to to themselves their
family and their mental health State and
and let me tell you something
um as a person who has worked many many
hours uh on on many many things and
making sure that you work hard in that
whole [ __ ] stupid old narrative that
it absolutely is not the correct thing
for your mental health yeah um you
pointed out
speaking in a minute you pointed out um
Elon uh is not in a good mental state
here he's even trying to convince I
don't know if he's trying to convince
himself or the world I think he's this
was his intention like this was his
original intention yeah like I think
he's trying to convince him like if he
convinces himself right then he can
convince
other people right you know because you
said Elon is busy trying to convince
everyone that he's not the fool
um and what you're referring to here is
his post this is a real thing
this is an actual thing the person who
just spent 44 Bill who borrowed a [ __ ]
ton of money to buy Twitter for 44
billion dollars
posted this on Twitter last night as
everyone thought that the [ __ ] thing
was gonna crash which it can over the
weekend I'm assuming if there's a big
problem over the weekend it's it's
probably I mean it lights out we'll see
if people can get it back open I mean
look I don't know what Twitter's Runway
is like I would assume they have money
to keep the lights on for a while
right but every day that goes by it does
make me question like Elon was like
we're burning four million dollars a day
probably more than that I mean obviously
not as much as that anymore because they
fired a bunch of people and a bunch of
people like [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm out
uh who by the way those people will find
jobs because they were talented and the
industry is literally watching this [ __ ]
show
[ __ ] happened before the rise and
they're like oh yeah you're the victim
here like you should not have good for
you for leaving and taking what you
could
but also if you want to join our company
we're hiring you know Gabe Gabe I
actually I think we've got um a video
evidence inside Twitter headquarters
there's Apparently one person
um inside uh Twitter headquarters at
Twitter support light right now oh [ __ ]
we just got sent this video we better we
better watch to see what this is about
let's see what the last person that
Twitter support has to say hi this is
John from Twitter support how can I help
you I can't log into my account oh
that's a security issue I'll transfer
you
hi this is John from Twitter security
how can I help you wait didn't I just
talk to you I'm not sure it's been
pretty busy around here lately lots of
calls no I'm pretty sure I did I'm the
guy who can't log in oh yeah that's
right yeah you just transferred me from
you back to you sorry about that not
many people work here anymore Elon fired
about 50 of the company and then a ton
more quick but I work at Twitter what
does that mean for my job oh that's a
human resources issue I'll transfer wait
wait don't get John damn it hi this is
John from Human Resources how can I help
you seriously you again sorry I'm
wearing a lot of hats these days
whatever like I said before I work at
Twitter and I'm locked out well did you
respond to elon's recent ultimatum email
about working at Twitter no because I've
been on vacation backpacking for over a
month well that seems to be the issue
you'll need to respond to elon's email
how can I respond to an email if I can't
log in oh that's a general support issue
let me transfer you no
and then it just resets and goes the
whole thing over again well you know I I
actually hadn't seen that uh Insider
video I'm glad you um sent the link
there it just seems like a Non-Stop Loop
like it's you're just getting
transferred from one person to the next
I know it seems like elon's our bonehead
of the week but there is a winner to a
poll a bone heavily Gabe Sanchez who is
the bonehead of the week we have three
great contestants here but who won of
the three contestants I mean it's none
other than the man in the middle
third time loser but I guess winner in
this show Donald Trump oh man what a
[ __ ] bonehead why did dot why didn't
he uh not show up I don't know dude
didn't it's kind of a
this [ __ ] guy he's making losing
great again he really is great again
is that why he's on the list is this
announcement that he made oh yeah 100
you could not go through this list or
through this week and say this guy
didn't get on the list right like this
guy through
and let's let's keep in mind two days
before
the midterms before the midterm
elections on November 6th
Rona McDaniel the RNC chairwoman went on
to CNN and said look if Donald Trump
decides to run we cannot legally pay his
bills anymore like we cannot pay right
bills and it's not because they don't
want to it's because they can't yeah
they can't she's like look we can't we
just can't do it if he does this then we
can't pay it anymore and up to now
they've paid over 2.3 million dollars in
legal bills around the and this is stuff
that was happening while he was
President right so these are things that
were pursued that they covered during
that time again over 2.3 million dollars
the RNC has covered and they said look
if he runs we can't pay his bills
anymore and and Donald Trump in the
crazy Bizarro world that he lives in
thought hey no better time than the
present I'm under investigation in
various States for multiple crimes I
will be indicted and what ends up
happening is he goes Yep this is the
time I gotta run right no no better time
than the worst possible time to throw
his hat in the ring well here's what
I'll say and I I've I've said this this
week several times on the show The Tony
Michaels podcast and I'm sticking with
this he is not running for president to
get away from indictments he knows he's
going to be indicted what he's trying to
do is run out the clock on a trial here
he's trying to position himself where he
will be a viable quote-unquote candidate
in the moment when he is set to go to
trial in 2024. it is likely that he will
not be indicted until sometime next year
and probably in the beginning but even
even that wouldn't stop like that's
right like it won't it won't stop
because because Hillary Clinton was
under investigation while she was
running
um and and investigations will continue
but here's the thing he is not Tethered
to reality neither are his supporters
but but one of the best moments from
this announcement because that's really
why I used to bonehead here because the
announcement flopped he spoke for over
an hour which is it was the same old
[ __ ] everyone it was very much like
2016 Vibes right right it was the way I
got it it was kind of weird but Jonathan
Carl here hands he's in the back of the
room this is a moment where Trump is
still speaking
um at the podium
just puking up vile nonsense but listen
to how Jonathan Carl reports inside the
back of the room probably low energy I
actually saw people trying to leave
um
before he was done he's still speaking
now yeah go back to the beginning
you know how dead it is in there listen
to what I'm assuming is a plastic
champagne flute fall on the ground and
you can still hear that and you can hear
Trump mumbling in the background
Jonathan Carlton one more time probably
low energy I actually saw people trying
to leave
um and people leaving early even before
he was done he's still speaking now uh
and and then they I think perhaps a
little concerned that that the hallway
the hall would empty out too much they
actually started preventing people from
leaving so now they're no longer
allowing people to leave so if you've
ever seen the movie Inglorious Bastards
have you ever seen that movie so at the
end the end the end the end the the last
act where
um Hitler and the Nazis get trapped in
the theater yeah and they lock the door
so they can't get out because the fire
is burning it gives you those Inglorious
bastard Vibes here and let me let me
show you the actual now Jonathan Carl's
standing there but he's kind of
preventing us from seeing these people
leaving
um the hall but let me put this up while
we're sort of talking here is here's the
actual imagery of these people trying to
get out right and if you notice here
um there will be a gentleman here that's
like ah he's cutting his throat and
pointing he's pointing towards the door
because right here right here see him
here nope nope they're not letting us
out is what he's saying there
um a lot of people are saying ah it's a
bad speech but this guy is clearly
saying if he wants the video again that
ah they're not letting us out it is so
hilarious that they didn't know this is
the funniest thing that we gave they
they know they have to go to like a cow
pasture
to have all their ridiculous
um [ __ ] like it you know like all the
all the costuming and people like going
to the bathroom and and porta potties
and showering at Planet Fitness and all
this crazy [ __ ] that they that you know
I've been here this is my 96 rally
but they didn't invite those people to
Mar-A-Lago because he would never ever
ever let any of those people that show
up at his rallies anywhere near
Mar-A-Lago
but the funniest part about it all is
the people who were invited in this room
are half-assed sycophants they're not
the [ __ ] groupies they're not the
fools the groupies because I've seen
other videos the groupies are literally
right in front of the right Podium it's
the Roger Stone the craziest the Mike
Flynn's the the the insanity which is
funny because some of the people that I
saw dancing and doing these videos that
were shared online were these same
people who were [ __ ] balling when
President Trump former president Trump
twice impeached single term grifter
Traders traitor lost the 2020 election
and uh they were videos of them balling
like actually one of them in the video
that I made about the um the donate to
the Donald Trump fund in that video one
of them is crying and later on you find
that one of those same people are so
excited and jubilated and all this stuff
they're dancing in front of the podium
because they're like I'm there I'm there
I'm celebrating Trump announcing he's
going to run for president he's going to
be president 2024 oh my God I'm so
excited last two years they've been
[ __ ] all getting blue balls and
crying to themselves because they didn't
know if Trump was going to run or not
and now that he did they're [ __ ] so
excited they've got they can't hold it
in here's what I'll tell you what they
should have done is is went to a cow
pasture and done this he would have had
a much bigger response when he was
giving the speech the crowd would have
cheered at anything he [ __ ] said this
crowd was like really he's gonna say
that [ __ ] again like he would have been
much better off doing a cult rally than
than what he did at Mar-A-Lago it would
have came off a lot I mean if it was in
a cow pasture you'd be like ah there's a
lot of [ __ ] around here right now
like it smells like it and it sounds
like it it is but they would cheer at
everything he said yeah
we have some breaking news on the
bonehead of the week
um live here on air we have breaking
news Kyle Chaney is reporting here news
A.G Garland has appointed a special
counsel to determine rather Donald Trump
should face charges in January 6th and
the Mar-A-Lago probes again with the
documents so more details to come he
says
um from Josh gerstein but here's the
thing is apparently
um Merrick Garland the Attorney General
of the United States has now appointed a
special counsel Gabe this is not a bad
thing I know a lot of people like oh
Merrick Garland's trying to kick can
blah blah what people need to understand
about this special counsel versus the
special counsel that was appointed
under Trump's Administration is it was
appointed under Trump's Administration
this one is appointed under Merrick
Garland mayor Garland is going to do a
much better job to make because he's
going to be the attorney general for the
next two years to make sure that this
this special counsel does their work the
other thing that I want to to mention
here is that this is why it's so
important that we get that 51st seat
um in in Georgia because that will give
the Senate full [ __ ] subpoena power
so they can be our our the body that
holds accountable uh Merrick Garland and
the Department of Justice and this
special counsel because we know that the
Republican House of Representatives
won't [ __ ] do that [ __ ] and they're
going to talk about laptops and and
[ __ ] Afghanistan but uh this is very
important and the reason why and the
special counsel is so unique
is because every single person who works
under that special counsel
is almost has the exact same power as a
United States Attorney so it's not one
United States Attorney and then Deputy
attorney generals who work underneath
them it is basically like a whole group
of United States attorneys working on
one task so this is super important big
news that uh Merrick Garland has now
appointed a special counsel apparently
for the probe of Donald Trump uh in the
January 6 Insurrection and coup attempt
and the Mar-A-Lago documents case this
is big big breaking news right here on
bonehead of the week as we talk about
this okay timing who is the phone Ed of
all boneheads and the boneheads that
could be boneheads Donald J Trump thank
you for running for for president in
2024 it's going to be quite the ride
over the next few years as you lose
again but today he's not a loser Gabe
today he's the winner of bone and so
much winning there's almost too much
winning going on so let's give him his
due
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ER you know yeah well it is to him
Donald Trump you are the biggest
loser in the history of
liver but today you are the winner of
bonetta week everyone don't forget to
catch bonehead the week every single
Friday here on the Tony Michaels podcast
in the second hour of the show and make
sure to watch our our shortened version
of the monetta week on the Midas Dutch
network if you're there subscribe now
how you can vote is go subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube go over
to the community tab click the community
tab you will find the poll there every
single week and as long as Twitter is
held together by duct tape and bailing
twine you can vote there too at Tony
Michaels pot at Tony Michaels pot follow
us on Twitter as long as it still exists
I guess the good news is we put the
bonehead of the week on every single
directory Apple Spotify Google your
favorite directory make sure when you go
find bonehead of the week on the weekend
where we where we upload it that you
subscribe and you leave us a great
review on your favorite directory do
that do that and don't forget every
single Friday in the second hour the
Tony Michaels podcast bonehead of the
week everyone if you're on the podcast
stick around we have a few announcements
we want to talk more about this breaking
news
but if you're on bone end of the week if
you're on my stats Network we'll see you
next week see you bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
the breaking news Gabe the breakfast
news and uh Merrick Garland is going to
appoint a special counsel apparently
that looks like that is going to be the
case I don't know when it's going to be
official is there like a are they saying
there's going to be a press conference
where he's gonna I think there's
supposed to be a press conference right
now okay
um um but I heard he has he's not on
stage I don't know what's your oh he's
not on stage yet well we're coming to
the end of the show so we probably
um if he's not on yeah it's an empty
it's an empty room yeah we're not we're
probably not going to wait on the
Attorney General to come to the podium
um here so make sure to check that out
make sure to get get your information it
does seem though
um that Kyle is pretty spot on without
wait never mind he's on he's here he's
coming okay here I'll give you the link
uh yeah well here I can
I can grab it let's do this let's go
live copy
and let's see hang on let me pull this
down here
paste
enter we're gonna go to Merit Garland
here
uh we're just gonna bring the C-SPAN
website up subscribed in court filings
in the District of Columbia is the
investigation into into whether any
person or entity unlawfully interfered
with the transfer of power following the
2020 presidential election or the
certification of the Electoral College
vote held on or about January 6 2021.
the second is the ongoing investigation
involving classified documents and other
presidential records as well as the
possible obstruction of that
investigation referenced and described
in court filings in a pending manner in
the southern district of Florida
I'm joined today by Deputy attorney
general Lisa Monaco
U.S attorney for the District of
Columbia Matthew Graves and Assistant
Attorney General for the criminal Vision
Kenneth polite
Assistant Attorney General for National
Security Matthew Olson could not be here
he is currently in Germany representing
the department at the G7 home Affairs
and security ministerial
U.S attorney Graves has been ably
leading the investigations into the
events leading up to and on January 6.
he and dozens of assistant U.S attorneys
and other prosecutors have taken on the
Monumental task of conducting over 900
prosecutions in defense of our
Democratic institutions
Criminal Division prosecutors under the
able leadership of Assistant Attorney
General polite have played a significant
role in those prosecutions
Assistant Attorney General Olson has
been ably leading the team responsible
for investigating the matter involving
classified documents and other
presidential records as well as the
possible obstruction of that
investigation
all of the career prosecutors assigned
to these matters are conducting their
work in the best traditions of the
Department of Justice
I also want to recognize the efforts of
the many FBI agents and other law
enforcement Personnel who are assigned
to these matters they are working
courageously and steadfastly and are
serving our nation honorably I am
grateful to them we all are
the Department of Justice has long
recognized that in certain extraordinary
cases it is in the public interest to
appoint a special prosecutor to
independently manage an investigation
and prosecution
based on recent developments including
the former president's announcement that
he is a candidate for president in the
next election and the sitting
president's stated intention to be a
candidate as well
I have concluded that it is in the
public interest to appoint a special
counsel
such an employee an appointment
underscores the Department's commitment
to both Independence and accountability
in particularly sensitive matters
it also allows prosecutors and agents to
continue their work expeditiously and to
make decisions indisputably guided only
by the facts and the law
the special counsel will conduct parts
of the first investigation I just
mentioned the investigation into whether
any person or entity unlawfully
interfered with the transfer of power
following the 2020 presidential election
or with the certification of electoral
college vote held on or about January 6.
this does not include prosecutions that
are currently pending in the District of
Columbia
or future investigations and
prosecutions of individuals for offenses
committed while they were physically
present on the capitol grounds on
January 6.
those investigations and prosecutions
will remain under the authority of the
U.S attorney for the District of
Columbia
the special counsel will also conduct
the investigation involving classified
documents and other presidential records
as well as the possible dis obstruction
of that investigation
today I signed an order appointing Jack
Smith to serve as special counsel
the order authorizes him to continue the
ongoing investigation into both of the
matters that I have just described and
to prosecute any federal crimes that may
arise from those investigations
Mr Smith is a veteran career prosecutor
he began his prosecutorial career in
1994 as an assistant district attorney
with the New York County DA's office
in 1999 he became an assistant U.S
attorney for the eastern district of New
York where over the course of nine years
he prosecuted matters ranging from gang
murders of police officers to civil
rights violations
from 2008 to 2010 he served with the
international criminal court where he
supervised war crimes investigations
in 2010 Mr Smith returned to the justice
department to serve as chief of the
public Integrity section where he led a
team of more than 30 prosecutors who
handled public corruption and election
crimes cases across the United States
in 2015 he agreed to serve as the first
assistant U.S attorney for the Middle
District of Tennessee later becoming the
acting United States Attorney
most recently Mr Smith served as a chief
prosecutor for the special Court in The
Hague charged with investigating and
adjudicating war crimes in Kosovo
Mr Smith will begin his work as special
counsel immediately and will be
returning to the United States from The
Hague
throughout his career Jack Smith has
built the reputation as an impartial and
determined prosecutor who leads teams
with energy and focus to follow the
facts wherever they lead
a special counsel he will exercise
independent prosecutorial judgment to
decide whether charges should be brought
although the special counsel will not be
subject to the day-to-day supervision of
any official of the department he must
comply with the regulations procedures
and policies of the department
I will ensure that the special counsel
receives the resources to conduct this
work quickly and completely
given the work to date and Mr Smith's
prosecutorial experience I am confident
that this appointment will not slow the
completion of these investigations
the men and women who are pursuing these
investigations are conducting themselves
in accordance with the highest standards
of professionalism
I could not be prouder of them I
strongly believe that the normal
processes of this department can handle
all investigations with integrity
and I also believe that appointing a
special counsel at this time is the
right thing to do the extraordinary
circumstances presented here demanded
Mr Smith is the right choice to complete
these matters in an even-handed and
Urgent manner thank you all
so there you have the Attorney General
of the United States mayor Garland
um Gabe Sanchez
it appears that
um what we've been saying is that the
Department of Justice actually does have
the goods on Donald Trump
um this is a thing where Merrick Garland
knows that there's a case to be made not
just not just in the documents case
which I've been saying is the
um the imminent danger to Donald Trump
being indicted but also January 6
because they're lumping that in and it's
possible that those two things have
something to do with each other that's
why they're doing a special counsel here
is that he's possibly stole a lot of
documents to cover up stuff from the
January 6
Insurrection and the coup attempt so
um folks I want you to understand
something this is very important because
a lot of people are gonna be like oh
Garland he's not going to do his job
he's scared to do his job this is part
of his job this is part of his job is to
make sure that when there is a a
situation where a former president of
the United States who when he was a
sitting president tried to overthrow our
our vote and then he stole documents
when he left and he's and he is
obstructing that investigation that he
makes sure that that investigation is
every single rock is is turned over and
and made sure that any crime that was
committed is prosecuted this is not an
indication that Donald Trump won't be
indicted this is more of an indication
that he will be indicted this is this is
the most important thing about this
special counsel because this isn't about
Mike Flynn and some sort of [ __ ]
thing we're we're a fired FBI director
triggers a special counsel this is
that's not what this is this is an
attorney general of the Department of
Justice seeing the evidence before them
realizing that there's cases to be made
and to make sure that it's done in the
appropriate manner under our our system
so Gabe what do you make of the Attorney
General's statements here yeah I mean I
know there's a lot of people that are I
see people in the comments right now
that say oh no I won't hold my breath or
this won't happen or you know they've
got the goods on them but they won't do
anything and they're passing the buck
off to someone else I don't think that
right like you also have to remember
that we literally sat through weeks or
months actually of January 6 hearings
where they went through and got a ton
okay well keep in mind there's two
different investigations that are
happening right you got the doj working
on the mar-a-lagos case and that one is
clearly under the purview to be like
look we need to make sure that we got
all these documents in place we worked
with Nara to make sure we collected
everything now that we have it and we've
we've uh
cataloged exactly what was missing what
was taken where was what he was doing
with it this and that all the accounts
of people that I've spoken to because
clearly they had someone on the inside
that gave them some insight into what
was going to Mar-A-Lago with the
documents case or was in Mar-A-Lago for
them to pursue
uh uh searching legally searching
mar-lago
so that's one where it's like they
clearly have a case there and probably
the easiest one to to solve or to to hit
him with then you've got January 6 and
you've got the January 6 committee that
did all this work in preparing all these
different things already working
in connection with the doj
so a lot of it's not like they're
starting from scratch because like you
you might be able to look at the Mueller
investigation and say oh well they kind
of started From Scratch that's exactly
and had to collect everything over a
two-year period And even though there
was stuff to point at trump it was one
of those things that yeah but you have
to remember too and I want people to
understand this thoroughly that the the
Mueller investigation was an
investigation from a special Counsel on
for a sitting president and the doj has
this idea that you cannot indict a
sitting president and that was the case
during the mule investigation you also
have to remember about the Mueller
investigation that bill Barr buried a
lot of facts about that investigation
yep there's a lot of facts that he
buried that there's more facts that will
probably come to light as the years go
on this is very important Merrick
Garland is is appointing a special
counsel to investigate a private citizen
the only the biggest reasons why is
because he is a former president which
makes him a citizen and he announced he
was going to run for president no which
he'll lose again but this is the most
important thing that this special
counsel will be investigating a private
citizen not a sitting president that is
the most important thing I want you to
understand and that is why Donald Trump
is completely [ __ ] here he knows he's
[ __ ] that's why he ran that's why he
ran and also I mean again I just want to
reiterate that they're not starting from
scratch on this they're starting
they're they're starting already halfway
down the field if you want to look at it
that way they've got video audio
everything that has been categorized
it's been cross-referenced there's
matrixes that are or matrices that are
made in Excel documents of showing who
said what where they set it to who they
said it at what time they said it about
what they said all of these things done
with the January 6 committee handed off
to doj the doj says great we got
everything we've collected it I mean
they remember those contention between
Benny Thompson and the doj they're like
give us the stuff and he's like not yet
we're still dealing with it we're still
collecting stuff and there's probably a
ton of people Benny Johnson Ben Thomas
sorry Benny Thomas announced this
morning that that they have more heads
of security that that there's more
evidence that they are collecting
currently even though they're that
special that select committee is on its
way out they are still collecting
evidence to this day that is going to be
handed over to Department of Justice
well folks here's the thing
and I know I know you want Donald Trump
to be indicted and prosecuted I
understand that as most people do in
this country I think that's the mood
and it will be done it just needs to be
done correctly because he is going to
unleash the chaos machine absolute chaos
machine when he is indicted and it is
important for the Department of Justice
to have a handle on every single aspect
of this and if you want to give the
football analogy this is a situation
where the football team like Gabe said
has moved all the way down the field
they're in the red zone and there's only
a few seconds left and they're only down
by one point
and the field goal the field goal kicker
is a [ __ ] Ace in the Hole here okay
they're gonna bring the team on to kick
the field goal here that is what they're
gonna do and they're going to win the
game right here right now they're not
going to toy around with another play to
try to throw another Hail Mary into the
end zone they're gonna go ahead and sync
the game right now with their Ace in
them because they're going they're not
going for one they're going for two two
things right now in connection with
January 6 and also the Mar-A-Lago I'm
still convinced when he said that that
the reason why he's he's lumping those
two in as one special counsel is because
they absolutely have to do with each
other oh yeah I I think I think the
Department of Justice has come to the
conclusion that he was stealing these
documents and he was obstructing their
investigation into him stealing the
documents because of [ __ ] that had to do
with January 6. yeah and not only and I
think also it has to do with the fact
that like we know based on multiple
accounts that we learned on the ninth
day of the January 6 hearing that he
knew he lost he acknowledged he lost and
said well these problems like uh
withdrawing from Afghanistan not my
problem it's for the next guy to deal
with which was Biden he acknowledged he
knew that he lost and if you look at the
documents it might be one of those
moments we say in preparation for him
leaving because he knew he was going to
lose in preparation he said okay let's
start collecting this [ __ ] right so
they're they're all connected and he
didn't want to leave and he thought okay
you know what before we really leave and
we really take all this stuff let's give
it one last hurray right January 6th so
yeah it is not easy to look at this and
say oh yeah these two are clearly
connected based on the events that
happen they're not unrelated they're
tied together absolutely well and Robin
brings up a good point she said this is
the first time the AG has confirmed now
the Department of Justice has confirmed
this because Trump made them confirm it
trying to judges because he's a [ __ ]
but um this is the first time that mayor
Garland has stood in front of microphone
and said yes we are investigating not
just for the documents case but also
January 6 that he's being investigated
this is super important she also says I
think the haters in the chat missed the
headline it it really is the headline
here folks that a private citizen Donald
J Trump not a sitting president Donald J
Trump now has not only the Department of
Justice not only
um for the case on the documents but for
January 6th he's going to have a special
Counsel on their entire staff crawl up
inside his ass and live there and and it
is going to not be a good time for
Donald Trump and anyone who had anything
to do with either of those
investigations so everyone we will sit
tight here have a great weekend
um as as you know next week is
Thanksgiving so I want to reiterate this
next week in Thanksgiving we will be
here Monday Tuesday Wednesday day but we
will not be here Thursday or Friday so
that we are not going to do a bone-in
next week we're not even gonna we're
gonna take enough time off that we're
not gonna even do a special episode
we're just not gonna have episodes those
two days we will come back the following
Monday but we will be here next Monday
Monday Tuesday Wednesday of next week
the holiday week of Thanksgiving we will
be here those three days so don't forget
to come and and spend the time the two
two hours on Monday Tuesday Wednesday
with us until Monday have a great
weekend Surfside [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ]
them
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon